all right you're good to
go thank you very much I'm going go ah
and begin the meeting of the New
Hampshire house fishing game committee
um as chair of the house fishing game
and Marine Resources committee I find
due to the state of emergency declared
by the Govern as a result of the
covid-19 pandemic in accordance with
house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet electronically this is a public
hearing of bills referred to the fish
and game and Marine Resources committee
executive session pending on legislation
may be
held please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
the meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I'm confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during the
meeting through Zoom electronic meeting
platform and that the public has access
to contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in the meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through electronic calendar on the
general court
website the notice of this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271-3600 or email HCS
le. state. n. Us in the event the public
is unable to access the meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff who are on the meeting assisting
us Jen for four our committee
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call vote let's start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
name also State your presence also State
whether or not there's anybody in the
room with you during this meeting which
is required under the right to no law
Miss clerk if you can call the
roll representative
con sorry representative K's excuse for
leadership meeting uh representative
close representative Spain here
representative Howard
representative Craig here representative
love here representative wolf here
representative kitridge here
representative
dsy representative
dsy representative Smith representative
Harvey representative
llam presentent um I have at my Lake
housee in Bristol and I am all
alone Mr chair should I start again to
have them make those
statements everybody who answered
previous to that is in the room in
person
okay representative
dville uh president I'm in my kitchen
and I'm
alone representative
King president and I'm alone in this
part of the house my home represent
representative
Egan representative Jack is substituting
for representative Egan I'm here alone
in my house in
nashwa
thank
you representative
rre representative
shirle representative Ellis I'm here in
Rochester and alone in my house and
representative
oxel uh presid in my home and do alone
in the room and Mr
chair I'm present here in the room with
all my friends
thank you Miss clerk I'm gonna again and
call into order um the meeting and open
the public hearing on House Bill
529 the one thing I'd ask is as
representatives are asking questions
please remember to state your name
before the question so that um everybody
in videoand knows who's speaking because
while that's a nice camera it doesn't
people can't tell who's talking so
please remember to just state your name
and the same with people who are on
Zoom representative Reed uh one of the
rules I I adopted for this meeting was
that if there's a Committee Member who's
who is introducing a bill rather than go
to the front of the room and get back up
and be the up up and down that we can
introduce the bill from your
seat thank you Mr
chair uh for the record my name is Ellen
Reed I represent new Mark and new Fields
Rockingham
17 uh this bill is a bill that's
relatively familiar to many of you it's
uh come before our committee uh a few
times now it creates penalties for
cruelty to Wildlife the language has
been refined over the last three years
in close cooperation with the fishing
game department drafted primarily by the
department lawyer Paul Sanderson with
the help of Colonel Jordan it has been
placed the language of this um as per
this committee's recommendation in years
prior placed in Title 18 the fishing
game title um and is written in such a
way that is workable for both law
enforcement and The Hunting Community in
fact in providing the highest level of
protection that's legally available for
the hunting angling and trapping
Community this bill also has the support
of the Fish and Game
Commission uh it was on the consent
calendar unanimous out of Criminal
Justice last year but unfortunately was
one of the casualties of our bodies in
action because of
covid so
cruelty to Wildlife New Hampshire is one
of only three states that has no
criminal statute currently uh for
cruelty to Wildlife I'd like to go over
briefly the nuts and bolts it's
basically three segments so first the
definition of Cruelty if you will notice
cruelty is not actually used in the
language except in the title um so
there's no ambiguous term of Cruelty
specifically the term is beat cruly whip
torture or mutilate that wording is very
specific because it um is in line and
identical to our current statute for
domestic animals that statute was
written obviously about a hundred years
ago with things like horses and farm
animals in
mind but in order to keep consistent
with current language that is the
language that um that we've gone
with uh you'll note that there are two
different penalties here one for
purposeful Behavior and the other for
negligent behavior in criminal law
they're actually Four mental culpability
States purposeful willingly recklessly
and negligently purposeful is
premeditated and planned with the
explicit goal of doing that exact action
it is extremely difficult to prove in
court this is reserved for only the most
egregious offenses people who actually
went out for the explicit purpose of
torturing an animal and they planned it
ahead of time and that can be proven any
other situation or incident would fall
under negligent statute purposeful in
order to keep consistent with our
domestic um uh domestic animal cruelty
statute purposeful is a class B felony
whereas negligent is a
misdemeanor uh it originally I had had
put this at Reckless it was one step
even higher however Colonel Jordan uh
brought to our attention that it is
impossible to prosecute someone who is
under the influence unless we lower that
down to
negligent the last section is the
affirmative defense section which is the
strongest legal protection that exists
it says that even if a defendant can be
proven say you have video of the
incident happening even if it can be
proven that the defendant committed the
crime in certain cases uh excuse me that
if uh in certain cases in this case
being if they are acting in in lawfully
according to tile 18 the jury will be
instructed to acit meaning that no utor
would ever even begin that
prosecution um so the language is it
shall be an affirmative defense to to
prosecution and an actor shall be exempt
from enhanced penalties under this
section for any manner of taking Open
Season time limits permitted scientific
investigations or wildlife management
practices lawful under Title 18 whether
or not the actor holds a current invalid
license so again even if there's a video
of just the most awful Behavior if that
person was engaged in a lawful activity
under 18 that jury would be instructed
to acquit even if that person didn't
have a hunting fishing or trapping
license there is no stronger
protection so just briefly I just want
to talk about why this is necessary I
did say 47 other states have it
including all of the best hunting states
states of every political strike you can
imagine and the reason
is this happens in fact when we had our
uh first hearing it was not my bill it
was another Representatives Bill and I
was sitting as a member on this
committee it was and I've been here for
a while and I I worked up here for a
while I've seen many committee hearings
it was one of the most gut riching
hearings I've had to go through there
was testimony that Turtles had been run
through with a screwdriver haved with a
Cleaver and left to die raccoons and
other animals chapped in cages with
fireworks lit in the cage some set
directly on
fire um these were testimonies given by
multiple Wildlife
rehabilitators so while that in and of
itself is a morally um abhorent thing to
imagine there's a more I guess um
Salient point to this the people who do
this kind of behavior rarely stop with
animals in fact one of the people who
testified in that first hearing was a
woman who grew up near a boy who
frequently would torture and kill wild
birds until one day he came after her
now she had managed to escape but
eventually after years of practicing he
went after another person and bashed
that boy's brains in and sexually
molested his body by the time he was
caught he had become one of the few
famous serial killers in New Hampshire
his name was Terry RM he was known more
frequently as Bob
Evans like many sociopaths he had
practiced fre ly on Wildlife because
Wildlife unlike domestic animals no one
misses so having a criminal statue
allows us to intervene in these types of
situations before sociopaths graduate to
murdering people but I would also say
it's worth just protecting Wildlife we
all know that animals can suffer we most
of us have pets of our own or or farm
animals we would not want those animals
to suffer Wildlife are just as capable
of experiencing that we are so proud of
our wildlife in this state we are
proudly rural we put images of moose and
bear on t-shirts and our license plates
and I think that if we really love them
the way that we act we should afford
them this protection and I'm happy to
take
questions thank you representative reer
any questions for representative
Reed representative
Harvey press the red button until you're
done so I just want clarification I
think what I heard you say this is the
exact the wording is the exact same bill
that we had a year ago nothing's changed
in it is that we correct we amended it
in committee a year ago that is this
this exact same bill that bill then went
to criminal justice and was unanimous uh
and on consent calendar thank you that's
what I thought I heard you say just
wanted to be clear it is not identical
to the first iteration of the bill which
was by a different
representative
any further questions for representative
Reed there being none thank you
representative
Reed next up
is Robert Johnson from the New Hampshire
Farm Bureau of federation who is in
opposed to the
bill Jim represent Spain if you could
promote um Robert
Johnson
Mr Johnson you should be unmuted at this
point go ahead and speak good morning Mr
chair can you hear me now we can sir go
ahead thank you good morning Mr chairman
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Rob Johnson and I
represent the New Hampshire Farm Bureau
is the federation's policy
director New Hampshire farmo is a
Federation of New Hampshire 10 County F
organizations we consist of just under
2,000 family members and about 1,000
supporting members and we are a general
Farm organization where our members
establish policy and direction through a
member-driven policy development process
and as as the chairman indicated uh we
are opposed to House Bill
529 as as drafted uh based on our
concern that in particular or looking at
section 1B of the bill is is where our
concern is and if you read it as
negligently mutilates or causes to be
mutilated that's what we're focused on
mutilated think of a a farmer uh uh
cultivating caring cropping land in the
instances where a wild animal is killed
or mutilated nesting Birds uh deer fawns
other small
animals our Our concern is that it it's
as again as drafted is is not is not
clear and we would we ask the committee
that before moving forward to please
take a close look at it with that lens
on
and I'll leave it at that thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr Johnson will you
take any questions I certainly will is
there any questions for Mr
Johnson there being none thank you Mr
Johnson for your
testimony next up is Joanne
borau of the new hampsh of the Humane
Society of the United States New
Hampshire office I do not see her in the
list of attendees
Joanne if you can raise your hand that
would be
great okay not seeing her we'll come
back to her next up will be
representative Timothy
Horan representa Spain if you get unmute
Mr
Oran oh thank thank you much Mr chair um
I I was a sponsor of one of the earlier
bills directed this topic so I think
this is a very U this is a
very very simple and workable approach
the um there is a um of course I think
those in the committee probably all know
this but just for the sake of others
listening in there are very clear and
simple and long-established definitions
for what is is a wild animal what is a u
fish and what is a wild bird um
situation the Farm Bureau man from the
farm build Mr Johnson talked about um
that is true I've uh I grew up in a
rural rural part of town so I've U I've
certainly seen um animals running when
they hay the field and stuff I think
that's um if you do that um that
wouldn't be negligent if it's within the
context of normal agriculture or normal
animal husbandry practices and also I
think that could already theoretically
be a violation because um this is 209
these this 2019 um D comes after two um
20 RSA 20619 which uh allows the fish
and game department to charge you with a
a misdemeanor I'm sorry I said a
violation a misdemeanor for like any
violation fishing game rules and U so
that's uh that's a problem which uh
that's a problem which I think first of
all I think it's not a real Pro not a
real problem and if so it already that's
something which is already illegal in
the law and can be subject to
misdemeanor penalties already so u i
mean so I think this is a very very
simple bill it's uh certainly much
better than the one that I was a prime
sponsor of which went down in flames in
2018 I believe but um so I think um
probably I should have just stuck with
what I said the gentle lady from New
Market um I think said it made a very
clear case I think as usual she said it
all very strongly so um I think I think
we should uh
I think we I think the I recommend the
committee passed the bill I recommend
the Full House passed the bill and um
hopefully we'll we'll send it on its way
so um thank you very much i' be happy to
answer any questions if anyone has
any thank you representative Oregon or
any questions for representative Oregon
representative
Smith hello my name is Jonathan Smith I
represent Carol County District 5 yeah I
have not necessarily a it's a broad
question I'm going back to the other uh
speaker just so I have Clarity on the
issue if um a farmer is cutting his
field doing hay brush cutting and he did
hit a a fawn that was H up in a little
you know patch of woods or tall grass or
a a nest of ducks with you know eggs
would this bill allow that fora to be
charged that that I think is a
clear if you would mind holding that
question I'm going ask Colonel Jordan to
testify in a minute to uh speak to that
question sure I'm not sure
representative Oregan is the right
person thank you
no Sor from the fact that it's only
negligent contact or purposeful contact
so that I don't know if a farmer doesn't
know there's a f there that's neither
negligent nor P purposeful in my my
opinion and um know damaging Wildlife is
already like a misdemeanor anyway under
the existing law the way I read the law
of course I'm I'm not a lawyer but
that's my opinion thanks
any further questions for representative
Oregan there being none thank you
representative Oregon Colonel Jordan
would you mind stepping up to the mic
over there and I think there's a red
button you can hit and I'll put you on
speaker um and introduce yourself and uh
and particularly if you could answer the
question around Agriculture and what
happens if a farmer who's mowing hay
runs over a fawn and how that's
addressed thank you yes thank you and
good morning Mr chairman welcome to see
on the committee and all the members
back be back even though it's a bit
bizarre it's nice to see way back um so
this is a good bill uh we worked very
hard on it because as represent Reed had
said last last year and we were pretty
confident that it was gonna go through
last year and I think it would have had
this pmic not yet the Farm Bureau uh and
so we when we crafted this we were very
careful to taking concerns regarding
accidental or or conduct without a
coupable meal stat purposely
neg we were confident the way it's
written today that it does that the farm
buau as you can imagine I have a great
deal of respect for because we would be
out of business Fish game without the
support of our farmers in the state so
that was a good concern I had a long
conversation with robob over the phone
over this and I am confident that this
bill would not affect that and I'm going
to give you a couple of examples to
support my position on that so just so
you know um pawns are routinely hit
accidentally in the fields when Farmers
R their hang the reason that happens is
because they're almost impossible to see
this past summer representative PE sent
me a picture uh one afternoon he and I
friends he sent me a text message and
showed me a year that I don't to this
day know how he missed but he missed it
and he literally almost had to pick it
up to make it run he just won't run so
it's very easy to do this is my point
and typically farmers will do this they
will um on in most occasions on most
occasions they will end the suffering of
the animal which I would encourage uh in
a farm uh situation that usually safe to
do that and then they in fact contact us
they're very good about the farmers are
very good about that we keep track of
this we had good experience with that so
the concern was that this bill in in the
wrong hands could then be used to go
after Farmers because they should know
that bonds are in the field uh in the
spring of the year M I guess I would use
the example of what we all put up with
on our highways so as you drive the
highways of New Hampshire you have a
very good opportunity to run over a deer
or moose at any given moment in fact
there are places that we have been we
have posted signs telling you you should
expect there are in fact deer crossing
here and yet we all including myself
continue to go up the highway at at the
speed limit and if you unfortunately hit
a deer you could make the same argument
that the farmers are concerned about
these days so I can tell you from good
experience of over two decades in the
courtroom a judge is going to throw that
out it's an accidental cause uh it's
some we call an act of God I liken it to
being on the road the same exact
scenario could happen on the road when
you see a sign that tells you that
there's deer crossing and you continue
on that you know it's a heads up to
watch for it but everybody continues to
spe liit if you hit a deer no absolutely
not that is not going to rise to this
level the other thing I that I would I
would assure the farmers negligence is a
u it is a scary term I think and defined
in our
legal laws in the state but I think they
they the legislators of the time put
some careful thought into it one one
sentence in that negligent statute that
I'm very happy about is it's got to be a
in order to prove negligent got to be a
gross deviation from normal
condu
a gross deviation from normal conduct
now I would call a gross deviation from
normal conduct someone driving out into
a field and running a deer purposely
that's a gross deviation someone driving
down the road and a deer jumps out in
front of them or a veiler going to a a
ha field a farmer trying to cut field
and a and a and a dough puts her on in
the path of that veiler that is not a
gross deviation that's a farmer is
trying to do his job that's a person
driving down the road with no intent of
hurting this animal so I don't feel I'm
very confident when I tell you I do not
feel that that could be used against a
farmer or anyone on the hway if in fact
it's every used against the farmer we're
going to have a lot of people driving
cars and courtrooms charged with the
statute every time they get because the
same scenari happening on our road so
I'm confident that the Farm Bureau will
be fine I'm confident that this is well
crafted and will protect those things
and it will also give us a tool we'
never had uh to go after gross
deviations of combat when we when we in
fact see that so that that would be my
response thank you Kurt Jordan is there
questions we'll start in the room first
representative
Howard thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my
question is it on now yes okay thank you
Mr chairman thank you Mr Gordon Tak my
question um talking about the road
situation uh I know I've driven down
down the road and tried to avoid a
squirrel and run it over
anyways uh so someone behind me might
say well he was trying to hit the
squirrel how's that play out in this
scenario well it's a very hard knowingly
and purposely is a very hard element to
prove that's why you don't see a lot of
that in in a lot of our major crimes in
the state because it's a very high level
of proof so again I would I would tell
you that that's an accident uh you you
didn't go out the intend to run every
great squirrel that you find you're
you're driving a car down the highway
like we all are these animals are coming
out on their own um as long as you now I
think the difference might be
representative Howard I one thing just
came to my mind was an individual we
made a case on who purposely drove
through a flock of turkeys with the
intent on killing them so what he did
was he stopped he allowed all the birds
to collect in the road he was waiting
for them to cross to witness to this he
he decided he was not going to wait wait
any longer and thr the car and drove
through the now that is a gross
deviation of normal behavior and and
that would be a crime I could use this
statute charger but if you're in fact
driving down the road and doing your
best to try and miss this thing or you
determine as a driver that it's unsafe
with SW or it take a step to avoid it
again that's an accident and not
charging thank
you thank you Colonel uh
Spain thank you Colonel for taking my
question um we had some conversations uh
Paul Sanderson and myself about this
same exact issue about a week and a half
ago because it was brought to my
attention by some members of The Farm
Bureau as well and it occurred to me at
the time well this would also extend to
people driving on the road because I had
only been thinking about this bill and I
did co-sponsor it but I've been was
thinking about still in terms of the
hunters and protecting the hunters and
hunting
activities um I felt we were pretty
tight with that the question that came
up um not so much at the time when we
were discussing it didn't surround the
act of the initial hitting of the animal
with the farm equipment it had to do
with the dispatching of that animal
afterwards and as you know not every
farmer carries a gun in their tractor
while they're out there doing their work
if the only object at hand nor nor does
every driver carry a gun with them in
the car if the only object at hand to
end the suffering of the animal happens
to be a tire iron or a wrench and the
person puts that animal out of its
suffering would this case be
then uh brought against them for beating
the animal and I contend no because
you're ending the suffering not causing
intentional suffering and extending it
and I wanted to hear from you how you
would treat that you're correct so we
struggle with this because um we get
calls from um farmers and others on I'll
get a call from a Frank motor vehicle
driver on the side of the road and they
have a gear who was who was crying out
because it's got a broken him and people
want to dispatch that we struggle with
that decision because I it's not always
great thing people do it I might get
away with that in Pittsburgh telling put
the down you in nashille that might be a
problem so um we hope that people will
use common sense and how they do it but
again I'm I agree if they are ending the
Suffering The goal of this is to end the
suffering um then they're not that's not
aor negligent part of so you have to
prove this statute these types of
statutes require that you prove every
element of the offense that's a high
standard of proof you've almost the only
the only way I can see this statute
being used is if you get and I'll use
the horrible example of the young
students up in Bart who who set out to
beat these ducks they beat them with
broomsticks for no other reason than
they were that was their
idea that fits this absolutely fit the
young man who stepped in in that
scenario and put the final suffering
duck down he took a step with no tools
to end the suffering of that last gun he
does not need that stand clear he was
trying to do the right thing with what
he
and in your scenario I I think that's
what people try to do we don't recommend
that obviously but I don't want to see
IES doesn't
that's thank you Colonel appreciate that
any further questions for Colonel
Jordan there being none our previous
speaker we were looking for Miss H bbau
uh Joanne has shown up from the New
Hampshire Main Society um and Jim if you
could promote her Joan thank you welcome
to the committee go ahead
and thank you very much and my apologies
I was on YouTube while you guys were on
Zoom so my first time uh thank you very
much for um for taking my testimony my
name is Joanne borbo I'm the
northeastern Regional director for the
Humane Society of the US and uh we
support this bill very strongly um we
wild animals um unfortunately are not uh
immune from these senseless accidental
cruelty in new or anywhere in the
country um you know we see many cases
like this and um New Hampshire has has
has done the right thing by uh domestic
animals and captive wildlife and we feel
this is just a really um simple way to
close the gap and loophole just for for
Native wildlife and it it shouldn't be
the you know who the victim is um it's
really the act itself that is uh that is
the issue here um you know we we don't
see biological ecological or ethical
justication for excluding wild animals
from uh from these protections and are
very happy to be on the same side with
the Fish and Game Commission and
supporting this bill um representative
Reed put it very uh beautifully earlier
on um the link between animal cruelty
and violence um is another reason why we
support this spell and and cruelty to
animals is is one of the biggest
predictors of future violent behavior um
so we definitely want to make sure that
we're able to intervene soon uh when
these cases happen especially involving
uh kids um and and hopefully Point them
in in the right direction and more more
positive uh Outlets um Shar with the
committee my testimony along with some
uh few uh further research on the link
between animal cruelty and human
violence so I won't uh take up any more
of your time um but I want to thank the
the sponsors of this bill uh
representative Reed and the other
sponsors and uh the committee for
considering this and I hope that you
will uh support the
Bill thank you Miss bbau is there any
questions for Miss
bbau there being none thank you for your
testimony thank you anybody else wishing
to testify on House Bill
there's a Gina and I'm gonna butcher
your name
sco you could promote her
please uh good morning chair and members
of the committee yes my name is Gina
scrano and no worri is there happens all
the time um I am a New Hampshire
resident and I'm calling today in strong
support of HB 529 FN I wanted to speak a
little bit um to clarify in what
existing law is and go over some animal
cruelty cases is um it this bill does
indeed Rectify a loophole um that is an
existing law
currently um according to RSA
212-b semicolon 2 New Hampshire is home
to more than 420 species currently
animal cruelty code RSA 644 semicolon 8
does apply to domestic animals that
being horses and livestock household
pets which is dogs cats and ferrets and
then wildlife in captivity which is
wildlife in zoos and sanctuaries Etc um
the endangered species conservation act
safeguards 51 endangered or threatened
species and the New Hampshire fishing
game laws and rules um provide certain
protection for 60 game species under
hunting trapping and fishing Seasons um
that does leave over 300 of New
Hampshire's valued Wildlife species
vulnerable to malicious beaing torture
and mutilation under the law and and
while those 60 game species are provided
certain protections under season rules
and regulations those protections are
limited um for example in
2017 a shark was brutally dragged behind
a boat at high speeds by three
individuals in Florida an image of that
incident showed that the shark's body
was almost completely torn in half all
three individuals were charged with
felony animal cruelty as the state of
New Hampshire have laws that protect any
animal and that includes native Wildlife
whether endangered or not um when that
case scenario was presented to the New
Hampshire fishing game not one
individual could point to an applicable
New Hampshire law meaning that there
would have been no charges in that case
um again um Colonel Jordan spoke to the
kennet high school case in 2019
involving the students from North Conway
who lured a duck which is a regulated
game species out of the water and
severely beat that duck with a
broomstick now while that case didn't
involved juvenilis and was handled a
little bit differently even if it hadn't
the New Hampshire fishing game confirmed
the only applicable penalty was unlawful
take and that is a violation under
existing law that comes with the mayor
monetary fine in contrast to that lack
of ability to seek suitable prosecution
for such a violent and malicious act in
October of last year two men were
charged with um allegedly beating
several porcupines to death with a baton
that was in Rockland Maine both of those
individuals were charged with aggravated
felony
cruelty and now so while some may
believe that we may have laws just
because we don't have Wildlife cruelty
laws in place um that we would be able
to seek Justice um in these types of
cases using existing law and regulations
that we have but that's just not the
case um and that's the case with no
matter how valued these these species
are including moose which only limited
permits are issued a year for the
hunting of those species um unlawful
take of a moose is a violation unless
conducted during a close season which is
only a
misdemeanor so the purposeful beating
cruel whipping torture of or mutilation
of a domestic animal um you know th
those types of cruelties to captive
wildlife in sanctuaries and zoos Etc
that's a felony level offense under
existing law there should be a specific
law in place that illegalized such
violence against free roaming Wildlife
as well rather than that current
requirement of searching for a
coincidental applicable office suitable
prosecution and those efforts which
nearly are all you know nearly if not
always feudal based on the limitations
of EX of existing law and that includes
game species in regards to the existing
link between animal cruelty and human
violence I'll speak to that briefly um
the FBI did begin tracking cases
nationally and categorizing them as a
crime against Society in
2016 research shows that there's a link
between 47 and 99% of animal abusers
have convictions for other crimes that
includes sexual abuse homicide assault
Firearms off uh offenses and
arson and those and um animal
cruelty um is uh is more uh highly to be
a better predictor of sexual assault
than other previous convictions such as
homicide arson and Firearm
offenses in regards to protecting Sports
men and women I wanted to highlight
again that exclusion that exists within
HB 529 FN this law will be placed
specifically in Title 18 and I wanted to
highlight some laws that are within
Title 18 and existing laws um that would
be CL included in that exemption to
protect families properties to domestic
animals and crops RSA
20726 which is in Title 18 that allows
any person to pursue wound or kill on
land owned or occupied by such person
any unprotected bird or wild animal
which the person finds in the act of
doing actual and substantial damage to
poultry crops domestic animals or a
person's
property and they may also authorize a
family member employee or other person
um requested to to do so under that law
or um using a depredation permit issued
by the executive director of Fish and
Game RSA 207 semicolon 22c paragraph 3A
grants the executive director of The
Fish and Game authority to issue those
depredation permits to kill animals
causing damage to crops or that pose a
threat to human
safety RSA 210 semicolon 24
d-b also grants sufficient game
authority over how nuisance animals are
handled in New Hampshire and
additionally RSA 644 semicolon 16 allows
residents to use poison for the
destruction of rats and other Vermin in
their homes or upon their
crops I wanted to speak really briefly
in regards to culpability because I want
to highlight that I do support the
inclusion of the negligent um level of
culpability for the misdemeanor and I'm
I'm grateful that uh colonel Jordan was
able to explain that for you in terms of
if someone is intoxicated but I also
wanted to highlight that in order for
someone to be considered negligent um
they have to um be unaware or fail to
aware the risk of causing this type of
Cruelty to the point where it's at such
of Nature and a and a degree that their
failure to become aware constitutes a
gross deviation for the for the from the
conduct that a reasonable person would
in that situation so that means in those
cases that you're discussing those
accidents with agriculture or um a
highwa situation that would have to be a
deviation a gross deviation from what a
reasonable person would do in those
moments so when you talk about ending
the suffering of an animal or you talk
about someone accidentally hitting
hitting an animal on the highway in my
opinion in those situations based on
what our laws of culpability are
currently for even the negligent um
level um that would not be applicable in
these types of
cases um and that and that is all uh
thank you so much for your time I
appreciate
it thank you jior there any questions
from Miss
Scarano sh being none thank you again
ma'am anybody else wishing to testify on
how Bill
529 there being done I'll let you know
that uh signing in in support of this
bill with 35 opposed for
four I will close public hearing on
House Bill
529 next up is House Bill 192 I'll open
a public hearing on house Ro
192 give the clerk one second catch
up represent McDonald great you want to
take a seat right there represent
McDonald soon as the clerk's ready we'll
go ahead and begin let you introduce
your
bills represent McDonald thank you
begin if you could push the red button
on your mic there
I'm sorry representative Lang but it the
it's inaudible on on the platform side
thank you
um representative could you turn that
mic so it's facing directly at your
mouth just tip it down there you go try
that uh this B is a request of the
constituent on October
10th cons send a email to fishing game
and you should have a copy of that we
question comparison between 45
ac5 really no difference any he asked
game how we can change that come of the
say you'll see a reply from Dan ver on
game program supervisor chish game which
basically tells the U constituents that
can't be changed by a adjustment to the
administrative roles but it has to be
done by a change thing and you should
have a copy of both those
emails um when I started putting the
bill together I sent a email to Mr Bon
where I spelled out speak of the changes
that I wanted
SP
calibers uh also provide original copy
email and I just asked him if the chish
game department had any questions or
concerns that support this type of
change in
legislation I never received response
from Mr I'm unaware of what their
position is all Mr mentioning
that
H and then I did some comparisons of how
this passing of this Bild would affect
other regulations on the law that I
could find and have attached those in
[Music]
particular three which is the taking
mode which list several different quite
a few
communities
Chang and 3A and 3B and wait
3C uh in conclusion I want to thank the
committee for the opportunity to speak
to you folks available for any questions
uh any technical questions uh Mr
MCU I believe next you should
be thank you representative any
questions representative
McDonald representative Harvey so I just
um am confused about one of your
statements um did you say that this
could is something that could not be um
um changed in the rules and of New
Hampshire fishing game and I I wonder
why it could not be done that way I
believe currently because it
exists
ands okay I get
it any other questions for
representative
McDonald if you're online if you wave
your hand I can see you
representative llam go
ahead thank you um this the
representative llam and I have a
question for the uh for the for the
representative um my question I guess is
why currently you're allowed five rounds
and your bill uh provides to increase
that to six rounds and I'm guessing
that's because most of these hunting
pistols would be revolvers um rather
than like a semi-automatic just because
you know you're gonna have like a six or
eight inch barrel when you're hunting is
it because of the revolvers why six
instead of five because most of the deer
hunting um guns uh only only allow you
five rounds thank
you uh that's what the constituent
requested that we change his s u I'm a
Revol
round that one round wasn't
repres I am gonna have represent uh I am
gonna ask Colonel Jordan to speak to
that issue a little bit
later thank
you any other questions for represented
McDonald there being none thank you
represent McDonald for your
testimony next up is represent uh is
William McDuff presenting himself Mr
McDuff uh you are all set to go good
morning can you hear me yes we can sir
hi my name is William McDuff I'm a
Hunter living in Carrol County uh as
part of The Hunting Community I've been
able to participate in several small
discussions with uh some fellow hunters
and it's our belief that the current
list of approved calibers for hunting
white tail in New Hampshire could
definitely be approved
upon um this current list would benefit
from the addition of the Cal before you
45 ACP 460 Roland 45 super 50 AE 357 Sig
327 Federal Magnum and 400 Corbin um
through my research I found that the
above pistol calibers have a higher
muzzle velocity in feet per second and
also deliver more muzzle energy in foot
pounds of force than 45 Co which is
currently on the list of approved pistol
calibers in my written testimony I
forgot to include that I'm also asking
for a change to the amount of rounds
that a hunter can have loaded in a
handgun while hunting the current is
five and I'm requesting that to be
changed to six um as representative
laflam mentioned that is because most
modern
revolvers do have a capacity of six
rounds um and thinking through this
personally I'd be kind of disappointed
in myself if I did try and take a deer
during hunting season and happen to land
on an empty chamber um I believe the
allowing these changes would make it
easier for a new generation of hunters
to find a passion in the New England
Hunting
Heritage and I am open for any questions
that anyone might
have any questions for Mr
McDuff online anybody want to talk
there being none Mr McDuff thank you for
your
testimony Colonel Jordan would you mind
stepping up to the mic to answer a
couple
questions thank you Colonel Jordan so if
you could speak specifically to the six
rounds versus five rounds um the
Department's position I I will make the
committee aware we have two amendments
pending that that we have set aside and
you've all been email the copy one of
which would bring us back down to five
if it's necessary so we have act we have
something we can take action on there's
also another amendment on the next bill
that will bring all rifles up to six so
we have consistency across all
firearms
so reviewed the commission reviewed this
didn't we were a bit hesitant to come
out an actual support of the change the
only reason that were hesitant is I'm
not familiar and others in the agency
not familiar with how these came about
originally so we're concerned about
saying to a municipality that felt it
was a safety concern well it's really
none of our business to say that's not a
concern anymore we should allow this now
having said that I tend to agree with
the legislation as it's written I think
if you look at the ballistics on these
in the bill on these two calibers that
the representatives are adding you'll
see that a lot of them are in fact below
what's already allowed in so remember
loaders are not what they used to be
have muzzle loaders that are very
effective to shoot very long ranges we
have shotguns that with deer barrels
that are rifled that send a slug out at
a long distance a lot longer than was
originally U common when these laws were
put into place so the only thing that I
saw that we saw the department saw that
we were concerned about was this bill
originally was asking for six rounds and
I get that it's a revolver and people
want a full cylinder and I understand
what I'm concerned about is when we we
create
legislation that confuses people or has
the ability to confuse people we make
criminals out of people that typically
wouldn't be criminals they make a
mistake if they get abused so most of
our laws today
20732 which talks about semi-automatic
and fully automatic rifles can only be
can only hunting at five rounds so I was
worried that if we didn't have a
consistent number here that we' have in
in one town in the state you could H
with five rounds but in another town you
could use six and you got to create
situation where people are going to
cross the line and they typically
wouldn't I don't mind a bit picking or
summonsing a CRI that's my job but I
don't like summonsing someone when I
walk away thinking that person really
made a mistake was confused on law so we
asked the sponsors to decide either five
or six we've kind of gone with sticks
and the reason we did that was because
what you've already heard revolvers were
being used that would require that we
also amend 20732 to lead six for all all
firearms across the board so no matter
what you hun with in the state of no
Hampshire if this bill were to pass for
this amendment you would be required to
carry SPS do matter how many what the
capacity of your magazine you have a 30
round magazine as long as you're only
hunting with six rounds in it when
you're hunting for deer or six rounds in
you will always be legal I think that's
simple it's less confusing for folks I
don't see it being a resource issue and
we feel comfortable saying that we would
support that change
I'm a little bit hesitant to say I
support the entire change for the
reasons I've already stated but the
commission doesn't I say that thank you
I do have one follow-up question for
that um so when a a hunter is in the
woods and he's carrying a three for7 for
personal safety yes he can carry it with
six rounds but if he's hunting with that
he can only carry it five rounds doesn't
that create a problem for enforcement at
timeses it does and that is that's this
would clear all of that that's why the
six round would be the way that iar all
thank you Colonel any further questions
for Colonel Jordan uh representative
wolf doesn't seem to want to go
[Music]
on is yours on y um colonel you raised
an issue that said you didn't understand
where this came from in certain towns in
the history of that are we are going to
be stepping on one or multitude of towns
Now by changing this law well that those
are questions that we didn't have the
answers to so um I'm assuming that back
when this became law it was brought
because towns were certain towns that
had the we call them shotgun only towns
that had these restrictions were
concerned about safety I don't know we
didn't chti game department wasn't part
of that so um I don't know how that
started so we were a little hesitant to
say that today it's we want conquer to
go back to the old ways um like you know
I think so two things I would say to
that one U my legal coordinator at G
Paul Sanderson did make a recommendation
it's purely his recommendation and I
don't necessarily disagree with it that
maybe having the municipal Association
review this would be a good idea um
that's one suggestion that he made
um and uh but as far as the um resource
hurting you know killing having any
effective power to take a deer humanely
uh all the other concerns that would
that that uh involve hunting and fishing
that we are involved in other than the
the number of rounds was the only
concern that we had um I I don't want to
speak for these towns because I don't
think I have the authority to do that
whether it's safe
or we don't I I can also say we don't
have a lot of issues we haven't had a
lot of issues follow up followup do do
you have any idea or does anybody have
any idea how many
towns excuse me would be affected by uh
this
legislation I believe there five towns
in the southern part of State yes that
this would make a change and just the
last
one thank you um and I didn't thank you
for taking my questions at the beginning
and I apologize for that Sumer time
getting back into it
um has any have we heard from any of
those five towns no and that was the
next thing I was going I don't want to
speak for them but I would think if if
there was a concern this is their
opportunity to voice those concern
concerns and I've not no one has reached
out to the department that I'm aware of
um to do that so thank you thank you sir
thank you representative wol thank you
Colonel representa
spine thank you Mr chair and and thank
you for taking my question um you had
mentioned briefly that uh ballistics on
the modern shotguns and uh modern muzzle
loaders are already in excess of uh most
of the handgun rounds that we're talking
about um I believe that this designation
of shotgun only towns has been around
for a very long time and uh so I would
imagine that if they were going to have
problems with the ballistics on these
handgun rounds they would have already
brought up problems with the modern
shotguns and muzzle loaders because
those are far in excess of what they
used to be would would you be able to
speak on that yes I would agree with
that and I base that on the fact that we
not had any issues uh in these towns uh
with that and you're you're absolutely
right the shot as I said earlier the
shotgun and muzzle loader advant
advances have have come twofold what
they used to be so some of these
shotguns are traveling up near 14 1500
feet per second so and the handguns are
far below that so I'm not I am not
concerned I personally I'm not concerned
about safety I think um I think we're
well within the guidelines that for in
the original legislation for that I
don't think this abends that I think it
updates it which is necessary and I
think that sixth round clarification
important because we'll create a
confusion there long as we can put that
Amendment on it so that it's easy to
understand for everyone and they don't
have to worry about boundary lines and
how many rounds they have I think it'll
be work that's my
opinion thank you Colonel any further
questions for Colonel
Jordan they being none thank you again
Colonel is there anyone else who would
like to speak on House Bill
192 saying nobody I'll close the public
hearing on House Bill 92 we had 22 20
people in support 22 opposed written
signed
in we are exactly on time which doesn't
happen often in the house um we'll move
on to house Bill 342 relative to the
taking a game by certain lever action
firearms and I recognize rep Spain to
introduce his
bill please give the clerk a few minutes
to catch
up
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I am here to introduce uh
342 uh which is a bill that I put in on
behalf of a
constituent I had tried to put this bill
in a number of years ago but the
language was far too broad uh the intent
was to add a of safety into the towns
where uh handgun only handgun and
shotgun as the the colonel clarified is
uh is currently allowed to also allow
people to use a lever action carbine a
rifle that shoots the same bullet as the
the uh handgun shoots uh the reason for
this is purely one of safety uh when it
was brought to my attention it made it
entirely way too much sense to me uh I
had to go forward with with trying to
push this and in the uh effort of trying
to move forward and show that uh that it
could successfully be done I narrowed
the scope to three specific calibers
that are very commonly carried in both a
handgun and a lever action for hunting
in the New Hampshire Woods that would be
the 357 Magnum the 44 magnum and the 45
Long
Colt these
three uh calibers when you're talking
about a hunting pistol which is a 10 to
12 in Barrel versus an a lever action
carbine which is 18 in or less the
muzzle velocity is typically less than
200 feet per second and the uh
trajectory and ballistics I've handed
out a uh a handout to everyone I can
also display um later on if somebody
needs to the the charts but you you
should see that there's a ballistics
chart that was handed out and if you
didn't get one there're down at the end
of the table um the
the uh changes at muzzle velocity are
only about 200 or so feet per second
which is not anything to really speak of
and the changes at 50 yards is even less
than that but what the lever action
rifle does give you is the added
stability of a shoulder stock and the
ability to much more accurately deliver
that round down range so there is less
chance for stray bullets and less chance
for missed shots uh or bad shots on the
animal that you're shooting at um I will
let Colonel Jordan get into more details
on that but uh it's my understanding
after talking with the commission and
talking with fishing game that they're
entirely uh 100% support in support of
the fact that this is going to add
safety because as anybody who hunts with
a handgun knows if you twist your wrist
just as as small amount as an eighth of
an inch off you are going to make that
bullet stray 50 yards away by feet
and having that shoulder stock
stabilizes everything I will also add
that at the request of um Colonel Jordan
and Paul Sanderson and fishing game
there is an amendment for this bill that
will simply add after the current
language it doesn't change any of the
language of the bill but it adds those
two sections in statute that we need to
amend from five rounds to six to bring
everything up to a consistent six round
uh across the board so there's no
confusion there's no mistakes and nobody
will accidentally have six in their
revolver uh when they should have had
five and uh I think it's it's something
that uh will benefit everybody and
prevent more of the situations that the
colonel was talking about where somebody
made a mistake but now they're a
criminal and that's all I have I'll take
questions if anyone has
any does anybody have any questions
representative
span representative flam has your hand
raised go ahead
thank you and thank you representative
Spain my question is um almost out of
ignorance when it comes to long guns is
there a particular reason why you
specified lever action carbins or is it
the fact that they only come in lever
action actually the carbin come in other
uh actions as well I went with the lever
action carbine because of the fact that
it always has an 18inch or shorter
Barrel so to prove the ballistics were
not much of an increase in muzzle
velocity from a hunting handgun at 10 or
12 Ines and in current law and the
colonel can back me on this in current
law the definition of a handgun for
hunting can have up to a 16inch barrel
so if you're talking about a difference
between a 16inch handgun and an 18inch
carbine where the carbine got a shoulder
stock and can therefore allow you to
stabilize it um that's a much there's no
difference like less than 40 feet per
second in muzzle velocity and uh and yet
you've got an increased accuracy um and
uh so I would say that that the lever
actions for the carbines are uh always
18 inches or less and they are much more
easily come by when it comes to talk
about these three guns that have those
those uh those particular
calibers can I can I re-clarify my
question follow up go ahead no uh thank
you represent of Spain I was wondering
why you specified lever action and I
didn't know if if like semi-automatics
were available I know they were
available in 44 mag uh in a regular
rifle I didn't know if they were
available like in a Carbine um and why
you specified lever
action part of that comes from the
experience uh that we all get as
legislators when we put a bill forward
and we hear a whole bunch of arguments
against it and we come back with in
another year with a much more refined
and narrowed scope version that we know
will pass the lever action carbine is um
one that is very common in New Hampshire
whereas the semi-automatics and whatnot
are are not as common and it also is
something narrow enough in scope that
there won't be too much argument about
what we're talking
about thank you very
much any further questions represent
representative Harvey go ahead so
um is this another in instance where it
cannot be um amended through New
Hampshire Christian game rules because
it's in RSA um it seems to run in my
mind sitting through numerous rules uh
meetings that the method of take is
something that is talked about there
instead of here at the
legislature I will let Colonel Jordan
speak more to that specifically but it's
my understanding that because of the
fact that we have these pistol only and
shotgun only areas that that are in
statute that we then now have to amend
the statute to say that lever action is
equivalent to a pistol in those or
handgun in those areas thank
you any
else on anybody
online colon Jordan would you mind
answering some
questions
no I'll bring that gentleman up to speak
in a minute um if you could uh speak to
the question we had about ballistics and
compared to a 16-inch revolver to an
18inch carbine and the safety
ramifications ofday so everything
represent Spain has said that I remember
hearing I was getting messages but I
believe is correct um the only uh we
didn't again the department didn't
support this change and the only reason
we didn't is for the same reason we were
concerned about the municipality so we
didn't see most importantly we didn't
see where this would cause harm to the
wildlife or the sport of hunting other
than uh the round issue again I wanted
it to six rounds across the board or
five rounds we kind of decide six
because of the revolver
um uh the question about rules is a very
good one so no Hampshire fishing game
whenever we come to this committee we
try to keep as much as we can for taking
regulating the method of tap some of the
tools used for tape in administrative
rules the reason we do that is that
allows us a lot more flexibility to
change those when they need to be
changed and things come up you know that
are while trying to manage Wild Life
resources as a tricky business sometimes
you have to make changes swiftly and the
rules allow us that ability to do that I
also like the rule process because it
allows the general public a really good
opportunity to have in not that this
process doesn't but the administrator
will process on mandates so it's a good
opportunity for people to get there that
becomes a problem when we have a a law
that's in place already that designates
a manner or method of take so we have a
law existing we either got to repeal
that statute completely and do it all
through rule or we've got to we want to
change it like we do this one we have to
we have to make an amendment to the law
so this is the right procedure for this
I am not an advocate based on experience
of regulating take all through the
legislature for a number of reasons I'd
rather do it to rule but when you have a
law that that states that's already
exist like we have here um the only way
to change that is going amend law
because a LW from a rule in simple Kevin
Jord language so um and that's what we
have here so we don't I don't have any I
I agree with represent Blain what I know
about Firearms um I think the lever
action was a good choice because I I
also agree there are a lot of those out
there a lot of people are hunting with
those types of firearms so that's a good
place to start um the carbine I'm not
concerned about the carbine being more
dangerous again you're in towns where
we're allowing saos to be fired out of
mow which are going at at at the same
rate as not higher in some cases so um
knock on wood we've had a good safety
record in those towns and I think it's
time to update these have not been
updated in a long time and this is an
update to that I think it's important
and I want to make sure everybody
understands fishing gang does we
wouldn't have brought this these bills
but we don't we're in a position where
we don't feel it's going to do any time
we're a little bit hesitant to say we
support it just based on the concerns of
the Town communities and this would be
their opportunity to raise their
concern hope I said you did and we won't
take offense that you don't like
legislatures compared to your
administrative rules at all that's
tricky um any other questions for
Colonel
Jordan representative
close Okay you aware uh probably about
18 years ago when this bill finally came
to miramac and they went to pistols
instead of rifles the trouble we had in
marac uh marac was going to shut down
hunting altogether Bedford was going to
shut down hunting all together and this
was part of a deal that we got so we
could use hand weapons so what what I'm
trying to say is this is very very
touchy subject I think we should have
had Town meetings on this because marac
right away is going to shut down
everything Bedford is going to shut down
everything Bo is going to shut down
everything they're closing a lot of land
open to Hunters by going forward with
this thank you was there a question in
there
are you
aware I am that was that was one of our
I think that was why Paul Sanderson made
a good recommendation in written
testimony that maybe
municipalities you're right that was
that was part of the issue this was a
negotiation without our involvement very
little of our involvement so that's
something thank you uh representative
Howard
thank you Mr chair Raymond H thank you
Colonel for taking my question uh is
there a uh a definition in law of what a
carbine
is I don't I don't I'm trying to think
of one I don't know of one that defines
a carbine we have rifles long guns that
are Define but there I don't think
there's clear language car
it would be that would be a
manufacturers term a type of of of
firearm that would probably be accepted
based
on based on
manufacturer recommendations rather than
law I'm not aware of a law that Guin
okay thank
you any other questions for Colonel
Jordan representative Craig
thank you Mr chair thank you Colonel uh
I agree with you that there is no law
distinguishing a carbide from any other
uh long gun but uh would you agree that
the general Firearms industry standard
is a long gun chambered in a handgun
cartridge that's correct that's correct
that's if I were going to prove that in
cor that's what I that's the
information thank you thank you any
further questions for Colonel Jordan
representative
wolf thank you um I am very concerned
with some of the discussion that seems
to be hanging out on the periphery that
we're talking about land that may be
closed to Hunters because of actions
that we're taking today I work very hard
to keep my land open for hunting and if
certain towns are going to start to go
at it just because we're adding two
calibers or something of that sort it
will affect a huge could affect a huge
number of people so I think we ought to
think about those issues I guess I
didn't hold it down um before
we
legislation
it it concerns me
greatly thank you representative wolf if
we can keep qu keep it to questions we
can talk comments when we get to our
work session um but uh representative
shirtliff go ahead just know I might
gather you down just for
fun turn about the
play
uh good morning Colonel just a follow up
on the comments by representative wolf
and also representative uh from Chester
um do you think it would make sense for
this committee to refer both bills 192
and
342 to a subcommittee together for the
sole purpose of allowing the municipal
Association to come in and talk about
any concerns they might have and I ask
that because I think there's Merit to
this legislation but it might dampen
some of the Town meetings to know that
they had a chance to have input in their
Association spoke on their behalf and
there was no
opposition yes than thank you for your
question it's good to see oh thank you I
don't want Mr Spain the represent Blain
to throw his laptop at me but um that is
a concern I I just don't want to see
Towns close it down and Paul Sanderson
wrote in his recommendation committee
may wish to consider what these
proposals should be referred to the
house Municipal and County government
committee for additional review and
comment it
may it may complicate it but it may also
prevent towns from uh reacting
drastically we we wouldn't want that the
department doesn't want that so yeah
that I don't think and this is me
personally I don't think that's a
better thank you representative Harvey
so I think I heard you say that uh none
of these towns had reached out to New
Hampshire fishing game
but not all towns are um as Savvy about
how to keep up with legislation and and
so forth especially when they weren't
expecting something like this to come
down the pike so my question is even
though they didn't reach out to you did
you then reach out to them um and if not
maybe um would your suggestion of um you
know referring to another committee so
that they would have a chance they're
they're probably probably more likely to
look at a municipal committee Bill than
fishing game we wouldn't typically reach
out to them all then unless we were
going to sponsor legislation like this
we would then do that um we've always
been hesitant to to I think as an agency
to to to support something like this and
ask that this be brought even uh in this
scenario because we're concerned about
what the towns have different concerns
and I I don't want to be a state agency
saying well we don't really care what
do you know there may be mitigating
factors so I don't think I think if May
complicate the passage of the bill but I
but I don't want to Lo no one wants
including repres wants to lose areas
none of us do so um you know if this
prevents that then maybe that's the way
to know I don't I will say I don't see
where this will hurt that safety piece
of it I think he's done a good job of
keeping this within the guidelines hand
guns and shotguns but I just think it's
important for the towns to have stay on
so putting it over to
municip any further questions
sorry col just I just want to make sure
because we've been talking a lot about
ballistics and and safety and everything
else and I I want to kind of summarize
so I understand what you said to make
sure that committee's on board I think
you talked about the fact that under
current muzzle loaders and c and current
shotguns which are allowed in these same
municipalities there actually have
increased uh ballistic uh ranges
ballistic numbers for these and that
this is these rounds are actually safe
would be for lack of better safer um
than some of those other rounds that are
currently already allowed in those
municipalities and lastly the issue of
accuracy and and stability that in a car
being compared to a handgun that would
be allowed that these guns are actually
more or allow for more accuracy
depending on the SHO of course but allow
for more accuracy is that is that a good
summary of what you're saying both good
points and I think if we're careful on
presenting them if we do a good job
presenting them I I think uh we'd be
okay but it's going to be a hard sell to
those folks that don't understand
ballistics like municipality so that's
that's going to be a bit of challenge
but you're right right and as far as
accuracy goes I'd much rather see
someone most people shooting at a deer
with a long gun hand the opportunity
much thank you Colonel any further
questions for the
colonel there being
none will uh in the attendees we'll
recognize uh The Honorable Jr hole who
wishes to
speak morning um chairman Lang and
members of the fishing game committee I
am here to testify in favor of this bill
for three reasons um all of which have
been brought up in some form or another
one of which is um as was just said it
is a far safer form of
hunting using something that has a
shoulder stock is is a much better way
to ensure bullet placement than with a
handgun two the velocities are similar
to
handguns I see this as something that's
also valuable to training youth we see a
declining enrollment in in hunting and
long-term um teaching ing young children
to hunt um carbin are the are the ideal
first rifle so um this gives them an
opportunity to go hunting with their
parents um in a controlled way and is
just a benefit to all around so I would
I stand in favor of this as both um New
Hampshire Firearms Coalition as well as
myself personally I think it's a great
idea thank
you thank you uh honorable H any
questions for Jr
there being none thank you sir is there
anyone else who wishes to speak on House
Bill
342 seeing no one we'll close House Bill
342 and we're seven minutes ahead of
schedule so we have to pause for a
minute give our clerk a minute to catch
up on pay
board a good chance for members to take
a bio break if they need
[Music]
it
was when that
came I'll tell you it was terrible we
had 200 people
there you just don't want to lose no way
I'm not right now trying to keep
it even the speaker had a good idea
oh sorry sorry I didn't
see I know slipping a
ton thank you though I appreciate
it that was good that was very good
combining both of them get it you know
have hearings
and
I've got nothing against the build but I
think like speaker said if you combine
them both and have hearings on it give
the people an opportunity you
know one of the interesting
things we'll bring that up we'll bring
that up this afternoon see what
you see how it's
operating very good you'll be
interesting after
so
Society
not
do
[Music]
is trying
to trying to nipple around the
edes comp
got have a second
job
yeah I'm
reading
repain repain you have the awesome power
to change the bill number very in the
corner which you should
[Music]
exercise
what do what they were doing most of
them who came
back they were
looking seen they
could you know they could
try you get on TV and get get
oh yeah I
watch
[Music]
that sometimes I think in
politics
what's your name close
k i a police officer in B that's why I
was involved with those hearings inac
and marac was gonna shut the town right
off so was
B that's what P the deal was that we use
hand weapons instead of using rifles and
shotguns and they weren't fooling out we
had 200
people contract they would they would
have shut the town right off this
legislation you got be very careful with
stuff like this here because
[Music]
everybody like rules fish and
being use the rules to manage the game
yes they have a
problem being taken they shut it down
the hearing fishing game didn't show
up they didn't
show get that right when there's a
conflict like that they
don't oh
God be very reason we got another we got
another big one coming at the commission
that's GNA
be
I
know
all right we're gonna get ready to start
here give everybody a one minute
warning
all right we're going to resume and open
our public hearing for the fishing game
and Marine Resources committee on house
bill 490 uh an act permitting the use of
liveaction game CRA cams and I recognize
representative Roy for the purpose of
introducing his bill
thank you Mr
chairman today this bill would allow the
use of live action game
cameras and what that is is a camera
Trail C sure you familiar with you go
Woods
picture let you know what time
that I action
a device SS picture to your camera let
you know
something now there's been some push
back I've heard that said you know it's
going to beair ADV
Hunter not sure how accurate that is H
you know that the first time you step in
the woods first 50 break the deer's gone
so there's no deer that's going to wait
for you at your family also
having said that I understand that the
commit is working on
Amendment incrementally introduce this
back I would do in favor of that
especially with regards to Hunters with
disabilities this is a boom for them
they can't get out in the woods check G
cameras every day um it's very difficult
and to let them get those pictures so
they know what time and when hand come
by is a good
idea I would say that majority of game
cameras now being sold are sold to the
cell their
device back when they first came out a
decade ago they were just regular
cameras you inwards had a motion sensor
on it picture the vast majority now are
radio Camas will
send to
cell so the what prompt to do this is is
a a question also enforcement
perhaps speak
this to your camera off
most requires you actually taking down
most people change their camera to tree
cable Lo
Bo well if you're gonna hunt that day
you're GNA go out there you have to take
it down and shut it off you're make a
ret
might so the question is how do you how
do you enforce whether or not sending
pictures to
somebody how do you look at it how do
you know if the person's got a picture
um there's a lot of enforcement
questions
the as far as the disabled HS go I think
this is great it sa them
trips
injur to check their
cameras and I do not see a downside a
population I
said I get a picture on my
camera soon as I get anywhere
near that
arum representative
Harvey so I understand the deer's not
going to S sit around and wait for you
but then why would you bother with a
camera anyway it what good does it do
because as soon as it as soon as you get
out there as you said you've made noise
and it's going to go so except for the
disabled Hunters I'm trying to figure
out
um why why would you bother sure thank
question well I guess at that point
comes the
question all and the point of that is
you know about what time the by whether
they come at all it giv you a certain
Advantage fact when I first start hunted
there wasn't thing kind
of sign
noidea
[Music]
and followup representative
Harvey isn't that the definition of fair
Chase well I would suggest the
definition
chases I mean at that point are you g we
should go
back
unfairly
UNF
disadv and by knowing where they are at
certain
time by no means guarantees that you're
get because once hunting season starts
generally CL gets their patterns CH so
you can go out and put the game cam they
all Su along of the Fall they disaar all
changes based food
based so IDE but it's not
a there's no
guarantee representative
Craig thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Roy I am representative
Kevin Craig uh would you agree that that
the use of game cams in general and of
Wireless capable game cams in particular
actually minimizes disruption to
wildlife in their normal daily patterns
by reducing the number of FPS Hunters
have to make into the
woods thank you for the question yes I
would definitely agree with that um when
you put up a game
camera you're able to especially a
wireless one you don't really need to go
back out there cost especially during
reading season prior to
that the impact of environment is much
less you have less people in
and
so thank you uh I have a question for
you I want to follow up with so would
you be opposed um on this current bill
it allows for same day taking how
however under our current
statute sorry give me one
second would you agree that this this
bill does nothing more than codify uh
fishing game section 31204 which is
titled live action game cams that says
you can only take a deer on the next
calendar day not the same calendar day
that's thank
you representative
Spain thank you Mr chairman
and
I thank the member for taking my
question um as an archery Hunter and
someone who who hunts early in the
season straight through into the winter
time I understand what you're talking
about with changing patterns and things
um I
found multiple game cameras to be
beneficial not so much in uh telling me
that a deer is there but in telling me
what travel routes are they taking um
would you agree that that uh knowing
whether it's a buck or a
dough is something that's important that
you want to know especially when you get
into the buck only season you're not
wasting your time and it's really
difficult to look at a pile of Scat and
decide that that's a buck versus a dough
or a footprint in the ground um and
would you agree that that knowing the
travel routes is the primary concern
especially when you put the cameras out
in very hard to access areas that you
don't want to have to travel too
frequently and leave a lot of scent
around thank you for the
questiones I would
with there's
definitely aside from rugs and trees
it's very difficult to tell where bu go
or
travel and scraping ground again there's
all sign natural sign but
especially
requ there's another aspect that regards
get c a lot of folks hunt areas that are
nowhere near the house there's people
that live Southern
Norther and it's very imprac possible
get to get up there um to check their
this allows them to know okay that stand
that I've got set up in this particular
are pretty active going out of there I
can go up there and um verus having to
drive all the way up there get the car
go back read
it so
it's follow
up I find your your point about uh
Southern New Hampshire versus Northern
New Hampshire to be fairly compelling
but would you then say that this bill is
is really a green bill because you're
cutting down on the amount of vehicle
emissions and driving such long
distances
I want to make a clarification because I
think I misspoke on my last statement so
your bill would allow for the taking of
an animal in the same calendar day
however the current are the current uh
fishing game rule is the next calendar
day um so would you be opposed to an
amendment that aligned this bill with
the current fishing game rule to put it
in the statute
your
question with the exception I would like
to see that it CIF that that disabled
people don't have
that I'm sure we'll put Colonel Jordan
under the gun to have him answer that
question hard to
get representative
Smith
okay this is just a question I guess of
clarification um if the game camera took
a picture of a six pointer say 10
o'clock in the morning um and you
decided to go hunt at that stand in that
area later that
evening uh and a seven-point showed up
at that stand but you weren't going to
hunt that six-pointer but it later
turned out that that six-pointer in the
picture was a seven pointer but you
really couldn't tell clearly in the
picture you then technically would be in
violation
uh of the the way the rule sits right
now this would actually free up that
ability to hunt the same day on a
possibly a different deer in the area of
that camera correct well it's my
understanding repr that the it's not
animal specific it's camera specific so
if you got a picture of a a six pointer
at 7 o00 in the morning you plan on
hunting the
afternoon um and you went out there hun
and the Seven pointer was there eight
pointer go you still be invit hunting
over the was active that day so it
doesn't differentiate byat by the Cera
itself which brought me back to my
question I'm not
sure there do I have
take
I thank
you any further questions for
representative
Roy seeing none in person or online
thank you representative Roy next up is
the speak in opposition of the bill is
Robert Johnson of the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau
Federation go ahead Robert if you can
unmute yourself you'll be ready to rock
and roll thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
once again my name is Rob Johnson and I
represent the New Hampshire fio as a
federation's policy director and our
Members Own and manage hundreds hundreds
and thousands of acres of land in New
Hampshire as an organization we do not
have a position on liveaction game
cameras our opposition to the bill stems
from the lack of a requirement for
written landowner
permission we ask whether or not the
committee move forward with the
liveaction language you move forward
with an amendment making it clear in
statute that written landowner
permission is required to place cameras
and electronic surveillance equipment on
private property the state of Maine has
such a law and has since for the last
seven years I believe it was 2013 when
it was passed to give you some briefs on
the the law in Maine let me let me read
that it reads and I I'm quoting
prohibition any person may not place a
camera or electronic surveillance
equipment that records images or data of
any kind while unattended outside on the
private property of another without the
written consent of the land owner unless
the placement isn't pursuant to a
warrant it also contains language
requiring that the cameras be labeled
with the owner's name and contact
information it also contains language
require allowing that the land owner uh
um remove or disable a camera uh if it
is placed on property in violation of
the of the section it also includes a
couple of exemptions that I guess I'd
say that we're not clear that they're
necessary but it's there are exemptions
that would allow the use of a camera to
deter theft or vandalism of a motor
vehicle when the the vehicle is
temporarily parked as well as as it has
language relative to the uh the use of
implants to a um uh on uh I believe it's
on wild animals to monitor uh animals I
guess it would be that would be
something maybe in in pursuit of a a
fishing game um uh then then also um
there is there's uh uh the penalty is is
for any person violating uh is a fine of
not more than
$500 maybe maybe maybe
levied this is an issue that has that we
as as land owners are increasingly
facing and quite frankly uh our our
members find find it unconscionable that
that cameras are placed on on our
property on Prop without without
permission there's the there's a term uh
the term private uh uh property uh is
used for a reason Mr chair I'll leave it
at that we thank you for your time and
attention as always and I'll be happy to
try to answer any
questions thank you Mr Johnson any
questions for Mr
Johnson don't bother
conc got kind of used to that I do
disagree with represent Spain on this
bill and and I I got some reasons here
that I'll U hopefully be able to
communicate effectively one thing I want
to point out this is a particular
situation where we don't have a law that
addresses this so this was addressed in
rule as a manner of tap um our position
is
always uh we try to preserve that for
the reasons I stated i w St it again but
it's an easier way to control this so I
would ask no matter what we do here
that's the better way to go because if
this requires change later doing it
legislative and present challenges so if
it isn't working sometimes you have to
wait two years before you get back in so
the r faster
um so we we looked at this when this
first came out I think in 2015 and we uh
we get a lot of complaints like the farm
deer like has stated I get a lot of
complaints from land owners who get a
little on edge when they're out on their
property suddenly there's a camera there
taking photos of so I have been
approached on more than one occasion by
land owners saying why don't we have law
hand makes people get permission for
that we have a law that says you have to
have permission to bait on someone
else's property a lot of times these
cameras are used during the act of bait
um not always but a lot of times they
are that's where I see the majority of
them so but there isn't a requirement
for a camera to have permission for a
camera but I can understand the
landowner I would I would not be
comfortable being on my own property
knowing my photos is being taken and
sent to someone I do not know without my
knowledge permission PR to that's me
personally we're not advocating that um
but it's a point that the F has raised
and certainly one I have heard before we
we felt that we needed to take steps to
do something against this because as
technology Contin to advance we talked
about it earlier today we were talking
about the advances puzzle ERS shotguns
as we continue to advance I guess the
question becomes for my agency at what
point does it stop at what point do we
say that's just a little too much now we
have a camera that will and what people
were doing with
this not every again not everyone but we
made several cases where people were
setting up dates in their backyard
sitting in their homes waiting for the
year to come they saw the de was there
back sh de that was happening a lot and
so you know what's next are we going to
have are we going to have a drone that
flies around with a rifle line so we
don't to leave the house of Hall just
can spot the deer and shoot it with a
drone I just feel like the principles of
fair Chase are an important factor here
and as Sportsman and I am a sportsman
Hunter long time lifetime Hunter uh we
need to protect them because that's
exactly what people that don't want us
hunting tradition attack uh and the fair
Chase principles uh really if you if
you're not willing to support that
understand those and support that and
we've kind of lost touch of what hunting
and fishing should be part of hunting
and fishing in my opinion isn't we we've
gotten way the society has and I'm sorry
I'm getting on my board here but but I
think it's an important fact Mr chairman
the people we've gotten away from the
experience of hunting and we've changed
that into the experience of taking we
didn't we term a successful hunt and I
lecture Hunters especially young Hunters
about this all the time a successful
hunt isn't an eight point buck on your
ti a successful Hunt is the ones that I
do where I go out away from my pager
away from my cell phone away from the
people in general and have a little
peace and and quiet and enjoy nature I
may see three deer that I don't shoot
because I won't shoot adult that is the
joy of hunting and and this technology
continues to advance us to enhance our
abilities speed them up make them more
effective in the effort of tap that's a
mistake if you're a sportsman and you
think your future is bright by going in
that direction and making a mistake it
is not that is exactly how we're going
to lose it uh the North American
wildlife model that we all subscribe to
or should as Sportsman would be appalled
by this these kinds of this kind of
technology I um you know a camera I'm
not even a fan of the camera I'm kind of
an old traditionalist uh when when you
ask the question should we go back to a
bow and arrow well in some instances yes
we should go back to a bow and arrow I
think crossbows I we've got crossbows
coming that are going to shoot two bolts
we've got muzzle loaders that shoot
rifle rounds we you know there was a
time when a muzzle loader you didn't
have a scope on You Had A Hammer Flint
Lo now you got Scopes you inlines you
got it just going we're advancing and
advancing and advancing and at some
point you have to step back and say okay
so when is it not appr and we felt these
liveaction Camas would the first step we
do make cases on them I think the guys
and I I have never made case on because
they came out after I stopped becoming a
real game Mor and was pushed into an
office but but I have seen tickets and
cases where the guys have made him and
I'm assuming they're making through
inter they're making them and quite
frankly they're always related to weate
and they're tied into action so and and
just think for a moment and I remember
there's no one in this room that I think
fits this m and I say otherwise quite
frankly um but if you put out an illegal
bait this would be your camera because
you would know instantly someone has
discovered um and so it's used in that
regard as well so I don't have a problem
with the camera itself I think it's a
great tool they take great pictures the
the other thing that Paul submitted to
you in writing that I I would strongly
suggest you read is he gave you some
examples of some of the technology right
off the ad ads on the website of how
these things are advancing these cameras
you can have 16 of these cameras tied
together and lock in a Four Mile area
that will send pictures within a four M
square area of your hunting spot without
you ever leaving your home that's ladies
and gentlemen is about as far away from
Fair Chase andics as you can as far as
I'm concerned so I don't want us
teaching our kids that I don't want them
to understand that's the best way to
hunt um I want us to not lose side of
the fact whole fun of hunting is to get
out there outsmart the animal and yeah
worry about your scent and take steps to
avoid that and harvest be I have never
put a game camera out and I've never had
a season I haven't harvested nice so I'm
living proof it can be done and I'm no
expert so uh as far as handicap Hunters
go you know this enhancing that we do an
awful lot as an agency because who
receive federal money required to have a
whole section of rules under chapter 900
that accommodates those folks we give
them we expend the dating season for
them we give them special privileges
upon their request if we can do it to
allow for over land transportation to
get in and out of these areas and the
argument that these are going to help
them they still if they want to harvest
an an they still got to get out where
this just so if you got to do that
you're gonna be out where the C and so
the need for that I don't other than you
could sit in a warm place and full of VI
gets there you know what time it was I
guess but again that's that to me is why
I face so for all those reasons um if if
it does go forward if the committee
thinks it's okay and we're going to push
it forward we would encourage you to do
it within rule um we would also
encourage you not to allow the taking of
the game the same day um because again
that's that's what people were doing
with it and I ask you to strongly
consider the farm bureau's concern
because that is a lot of our open land
and if we got land owners pushing back
we need to be we need to be aware of
that and willing to
address hopefully I didn't make
anybody you're fine Colonel um
representative spellen
thank you Mr chair and thank you Colonel
Jordan for taking my questions um I'll
start out first by asking you you you
mentioned that people were using these
in their backyards so they could see the
deer come and then run outside and shoot
it if that's the case wouldn't it be
more efficient for them to use a home
security camera mounted on the back of
the house as I've got on my house and
then this there's no violation against
that because there's nothing in the
statute that says you can't use a home
security camera to monitor your property
and you're still accomplishing the same
thing you are as long as that bait is
the only thing I would say about home
security is that would probably require
that the bait closer to the home we do
have regulations for that so it'll be
harder to do but I'm sure people do that
I don't want to make it easier for is
what I'm saying I have a wireless camera
that sits way out at my chicken coup
just so you know follow follow up I have
another question does fishing game not
use these cameras for law enforcement we
do not we well I shouldn't say we did
use them on the coast for the elvers yes
when we had a rampage of el poaching if
you remember that the market we did use
that because it was safer than having
offers sit out there in the dark it was
safer to have a camera and they had
knowledge prior to getting there who was
there so yes we did use them to wa we
don't we're not using them commonly now
because quite frankly they're expensive
the data fee for sending that data is
expensive so I don't allow them to be
used unless we're in with the older
situation that's that you bring up
another Val point I didn't touch you on
I'm a
little okay I'm a little hinky about
them as well due to officer I'm not real
comfortable with my officers going out
in the woods to check a DAT site and
being photographed instantly and sent to
someone so that they have the ability to
know the officers there at that moment
I'm not real comfortable with that so
but that's not the driving
for I think that could be an issue
followup question representa
Spain thank you again and thank you
again um my final question touches on
the disabilities aspect um you had
mentioned that uh you'd like to keep
this whole thing um it actually touches
on the disabilities and Farm Bureau
because you mentioned those together uh
those concerns um you mentioned you'd
rather keep it in rules because that's
where things could be changed quickly
couldn't you currently cautify that
disabled people have the ability to use
these cameras when they have a mobility
issue and put that in rules and also
address the situation with needing L
written land owner permission for camera
placement in rules the same way as uh
tree STS that pump that penetrate a tree
is in rules for written landowner
permission Etc all of that could
yes follow real quick last followup can
I ask why that hasn't been done yet as
far as written landowner permission for
camera placement sure uh written L for
camera replacement people have mentioned
it to me was the no driving force to do
that I've not had a single request from
the handicap Hunter to my knowledge to
use a liveaction game camera if we had
we would have address that we've had
when they when they come to us over
Mobility or the extension of if you
remember few years ago at a committee
extensional debating rules those types
of things we do do I've not had a single
handicap person come to us for that uh
and and uh ra the first time I heard and
organized uh Farm buau concern was from
Rob the other day when we start talking
with this but I've had numerous land
owners mention to me is it legal the
question comes more represents as a
phone call or when they meet you is it
legal to have a camera on my property
without my permission my answer is yes
and then they give me an opinion of that
that is if I went out and wrote a rule
every time I heard that I would be at JL
car full time because I hear that kind
of stuff all the time but I have no
objections to anything that we just said
if we should review that rule uh and the
general public wants that then yeah we
should be doing that I I don't like it
in law and you know all the reasons
why so that's why
reest thank you representative dville go
ahead and unmute yourself and ask your
question
uh thank you Mr chair and uh thank you
Colonel Jordan for taking my question uh
the one thing that uh can you guys all
hear me well
there okay thank you um my question is
um with the frequenc do you
see um the the possibility of hunters
with multiple
cameras um being able to easily abused
the opportunity to use multiple cameras
because I I tend to see this up up north
where there's lots of cameras already uh
they're already you can go to Cabellas
and get them all over the place uh like
you mentioned stringing them together
where somebody as opposed to it being
green could actually be in a
car like you had mentioned in a four
square mile area they could be roaming
around in their car and hear a ping on
their phone and know exactly where
they're going so is it this a potential
bill that could be easily abused and
hard to
track yes the answer that shortly yes
but you know these they sell a kit that
contains four long range infrared
cameras for instance in a private camera
camera Network that allows you to link
up to 16 cameras communic with each
other don't require Wi-Fi or cellular
service each photo that's taken in your
camera network is sent directly to your
home camera this came off an ad for
these Camas allowing you to view them
all in one place without spooking game
or disrupting your Hotpot each trail
camera has AAL range of quarter mile
dense woods and more than a mile in open
terrain this could automatically allow
you to sink together um and creating a
daisy chain that extends photo
transmission four miles so the other
argument I would make about the green
argument which which is almost as
laughable as the green argument but one
other thing that we should think about
don't we want Hunters coming to the
North country and renting a room whether
they get a deer or not and buying a
buying a dinner and going out hunting I
don't want them staying home I want them
coming up here and so that could be You
could argue that point on both sides and
I think if you argu that in North
Country it would come down on they want
the hunters there so I certain so I I
don't know that's going to save us any
fuel I'd like to see them coming up and
buying rooms and
nice save Colonel um any other questions
for Colonel
Jordan there being none thank you
Colonel
Jordan as a last person who has signed
up to testify is anybody online who
wishes to testify for house bill um 480
490 I'm
sorry s close the hearing on House Bill
490 and we will move in to House Bill
241 open a public hearing on House Bill
241 an act relative to
trout and I don't see representative uh
aini
here uh he's online uh we'll recognize
representative aini to speak to
introduce his Jo go ahead
representative thank you Mr chairman
thank you members of the committee I
bring this Bill forward on behalf of a
constituent and while I've learned a lot
about trout he had he has a vast greater
knowledge than I do so I would ask that
the committee hold questions until Mr
Wallace has a chance to
testify any questions for representative
aini there being none thank you
representative enjoy your rest of your
day uh next up is representative Walsh
if he's
online representative Walsh you've been
promoted the panelist go ahead and uh
speak can you hear me go ahead Sir Mr
Walsh Mr Walsh um I I sent a an email to
everybody who uh whose emails I could
get uh forgive me um I'm a special needs
teacher I'm at school in my classroom
right now so I might be have to be brief
um I'm just a a fly fisherman of some 50
something years I live in
Effingham
um while up well the state maintains 16
waters for the trout for brook trout
salinus salvelinus Fountain Alice which
is the state freshwater fish these
waters are designated by there signage
on them that says they're managed for
wild trout wild brook trout I'm sorry um
looking in that and again just being a
concerned Citizen and something of a you
know as I said devout fly fisherman I
went to the
regulations and in the
rules where it discusses it's FIS 4067
wild trout Waters it just mentions that
this water body shall be manag for wild
trout now it may not seem like much but
uh fly fishermen are like golfers I mean
we're kind of addicts and we might get
you know there's a thousand questions
and a thousand opinions and I was just
thinking that it might be worth a while
to add to make the to make the the the
the rules match the signage so I was
hoping to add the word wild brook
trout onto FIS
4607 and I took it one step further and
I looked at the RSA on Brook TR trout
and it defines brook trout rather
Loosely it includes rainbow trout brown
trout lock leav trout and other trouts
that are hybrids and actually sort of
invasive species I mean fishing game
uses them to supplant I mean not
supplant to supplement um the game
Waters which is you know fine but I saw
a little bit of an an issue where if a
water is specifically managed for wild
brook trout yet brook trout or man can
be defined as any of four species it
just opened up something of a can of
worms in my mind I mean perhaps that
could have just been me but I talked to
representative avalani and we we put
this forward um I I was reached M
representative Alice Ellen Reed reached
out last week and she had a constituent
who was discussing it and we had a nice
conversation and we came up with uh what
would be an amended version which
actually sort of hopefully clarifies
a little bit of the
definitions and hopefully sort of does
what I was hoping to do which is just
protect those 16 wild trout wild brook
trout
Waters
um my my hope is that you know we can
just limit it to that there's a whole
bunch of side issues relative to this
there's Wild versus native trout there's
bi biological discussions I mean there's
a slew of things that that uh can be
touched on when you sort of open this
particular can of worms but my intent
was just to sort of clean up the
definition so that our state fish in the
waters that are specifically set aside
for it you know has the protection of
the definition being correct um you know
I'm not trying to to to change much more
than that you know perhaps at this point
I'm open to these discussions but you
know that was my intent just to sort of
take these 16 Waters and make sure that
they're protect right I mean I don't
doubt fishing game I know that their
intent is right but again 20 years from
now if the law is still the same you
know what might happen there might be
room for for error or confusion or you
know there's there's a gray area there
and again all I was hoping to do is just
sort of close this particular loophole I
believe representative Reed and I had a
you know came to a wonderful conclusion
and I mean at this point in time that
amended version that she and that we
discussed is is is the one that I'm very
happy with so that's you know I set up a
presentation but uh barring that and
with the discussion over the past week
um my presentation kind of became
moot so you know literally like I said
it's it's it's a very simple or my mind
a very simple thing fishing game said
they would need time to go through it uh
chairman Lang discussed it with them and
hopefully you know as it sits all
parties to this are happy um I'm very
happy with it so that's you know if
there's any questions I'm more than
happy to answer otherwise I might have
to cut out and get back to teaching math
for a
bit thank you Mr waler any questions for
Mr
Walsh there being none go back to
students and enjoy teaching math oh Mr
re I apologize there was one question
for you representative wolf go ahead oh
um if um I understand that you're
comfortable with the amendment that
would go with this oh yes yes um I had I
had approached uh originally hope hoping
to have the change it well the original
thought was to add the word Brook into
the water bodies manag for wild trout
and change the definition I think the uh
the uh Legal Services people sort of
combined the two with the original Bill
and it in my mind it it sort of left out
the protection for the wild trout Waters
the amended version that that
representative Reed and I discussed does
that I'm very happy with the wordage in
in that one so yes
absolutely thank you thank you any
further questions for Mr
Walsh there being none thank you again
Mr
Walsh
is there anybody else who wishes to
speak on House Bill 241 relative to
trout and Colonel I am gonna have you
come up and testify in a minute uh but
I'll recognize um Jason stock um to
speak good good morning uh this is Jason
stock I'm the executive director of the
New Hampshire Timberland owners associ
assciation and uh thank you for allowing
me to speak on this bill we we are uh we
did I did not intend to speak on it but
what I would like to request is if it
would be possible to see the
amendment uh before it it gets acted on
um for the simple reason that many of
these trout streams are on our members
property and what we don't want to see
occur or what
we're concerned about is that if there
is going to be a additional form of
Regulation controls or management
associated with specific streams we
would at least appreciate the
opportunity to see what is being
proposed so that um we know what's
what's occurring in in the general court
and by extension on our ability to
manage for forestry and Forest
management um
right now in particularly in Coos County
and many of the unincorporated places
there are special zones that have
reparan areas um associated with trout
streams and if this proposal is going to
change what is defined as a trout stream
somehow that may
change which uh well thank you uh that
may change which streams are in fact
falling into this so I would I see it on
the screen now now and I appreciate that
um would like an opportunity to also
talk to some of the land managers
associated with those properties to see
if this would in fact affect their
property and their ability to do the
forestry on their
property with that I will like I said I
didn't have any prepared comments but
I'd be happy to try to answer any
questions
thank you Mr stock any questions from Mr
stock looks like you're all set to go
Jason thank you
chairman colon Jordan would you like to
step up to the seat again I tell you I
have been scrambling to try and find a
Fisheries biologist and failed uh
someone will pay for that uh but I will
say that the amendment I don't believe
that the
I know the commission has not seen it to
be able to take a position on they did
have concerns about the original bill
and the reasons that they had concerns
it was it back past and the definition
changed we would have to go back in and
change all of the 400 rules it would be
an expense for us for signage and and
the Mr Walsh I believe brought up a very
good point in that wild brook trout are
referred to by many different people in
many different ways so you need to be
really careful I would do that I put in
stock book TR and and stocking off a
stocking truck and back an hour later to
have a fisherman show me that made a
book TR that just got had to be made it
because look at so there there's going
to be some confusion there uh we need to
I think move slowly on that to make sure
that people understand so we again don't
make criminals people be criminals so I
would ask that we I can't say we support
the amendment
because Jason BRS up good point land
owners I would ask if we move kind
slowly make sure that we get it right
when we do it um the amendment to me
looking than the amendment looks clear I
think we're on way and I was kind of
looking for input from my fish file just
make sure
concerns thank you uh represent Spain
for a question
yes thank you Mr chair and I thank you
Colonel Jordan for taking my question um
is it true that the native Brook Trout
the one that's native to New Hampshire
is actually called a Char and if that's
the case with that I've heard why is
that language not listed in the
amendment as one of the names a Char is
a juvenile fish name a Native fish brook
trout is a
fish brook trout came here natural not
something brought in AAR is a juvenile
fish b b juvenile
and that's really pushing my
biological any further questions for
Colonel
Jordan so col Jordan again if I can
summarize what you said to me the the
original Bill had the original bill has
problems and it creates regulatory
problems for you under current current
regulations anying cost the new
definition you just haven't had a chance
to look at to see if it's it's going to
work work with the current statutes or
not CH to it it looks better to me it
looks clear but I would want them to
have that opportunity and I would really
like to have the committee maybe even
work with Jason Smith fish in Fish to
make sure we can create something that
solves both Mr concern without affecting
land
owners thank you Colonel thank you
anyone
else
so uh Jason Smith has his hand raised in
the attendees we'll again unmute him so
he can speak Jason if you unmute your
microphone you can go ahead and
go and you're still muted
sir okay we're gonna move on to there he
is you're unmuted now good morning sir
this is Jason Smith with New Hampshire
fishing game um just thought i' chime in
to uh kind of strengthen Colonel
Jordan's testimony um briefly so the
original Bill had some fundamental
problems that seem really simple on the
surface um one being that because
historically we've always
included all three species of trout and
their
hybrids in our uh lumped into our season
dates and bag limits to change the
definition of a brck trout without going
through some proper planning would
ultimately
eliminate all the season dates of bag
limits for Browns and rainbow trout so
that was that was the first major red
flag on the initial
bill um so that would obviously cause a
lot of problems the um in the amendment
I think there's some confusion here as
to what a wild trout is and what a wild
trout management plan is we have over
2500 streams and rivers in the state of
New Hampshire that have documented wild
brook trout populations which brings you
to the next question is what is actually
defined as management uh we have what's
a wild trout Management program that is
specific to Wild brook trout Although
our rule does not specify brook trout it
is it is trout it's areas that we do not
stock it is areas that is artificial l
or only or fly and all fish must be
caught and immediately released so with
um so that's kind of Point number two uh
the third thing is this statute as it
reads now neglects to list lake trout
you know lake trout are native to New
Hampshire they originated in six of our
cold large deep water
lakes and this would also lump them into
the existing bag limits or remove their
bag limits all together uh rather than
to be the two fish 18inch
limit um and looking at some of the
Amendments the amendment tries to lump
all the water bodies in a specific table
T titled table
400.1 table 400.1 if you go through our
FIS
manual is every water body in the state
of New Hampshire that is a pond
that has special regulations on it some
of these special regulations are things
such as some of our quality Bass
Tournament regulations so a lot of these
water bodies that are listed in table
400.1 do not even have brook trout in
even more so while brook trout inhabited
with
them so I just would proceed with
caution on this because it seems simple
on the surface but there is a lot going
on here uh and with that I would more
been more than happy to take any
questions any questions for Mr Smith
from Vision game representative
Harvey so with those problems that you
mentioning which seem rather significant
to me um is this sometimes we can fix a
bill and sometimes we just need to start
over again is this a bill that you think
is actually fixable or should we start
from scratch in your
opinion not with extensive work and as I
mentioned earlier I think it would
probably be best handled through rule um
just because a lot of our specificity
and our real details in our fishing
management and regulations lies in rule
um so I I think it's probably best
handled
there anyone else for Mr
Smith
thank you Mr Smith we'll move on to
Steve angers who wishes to speak from
the attendee
list Mr angers you need to unmute
yourself
please thank you thank you Mr chairman
uh members of the committee uh Steve
Anders Conway New
Hampshire uh I'm the owner of the North
Country Angler
the uh longest continually operating Fly
Shop in New England at this
point um I'm also a member of child
unlimited and
um we've been working very closely with
Jason Smith and his team to work on
these particular issues that are being
brought forward to the
committee uh it's my understanding that
something like this could be done by
rule not necessarily by
legislation and um I've attended every
Commission meeting in the last four and
a half years and I don't recall anybody
having had this brought forward by
petition to the commission to have a
rule
change um I don't profess to be an
expert on any of this but it just seems
to me that if uh this could be done by
rule change
um and take care of all of the issues
that have been brought up uh during this
discussion so um that's what I'd like to
put forward to the group and I certainly
would answer any
questions any question for Mr
angers seeing none thank you
sir on the hot seat one more
second
so I just have a clarification question
so again I think this becomes one of
those things where we have in statute we
also have in regulation and what happens
with this because we have a definition
here that I think the understanding is
that this definition is referenc in all
your regulations and if we change it
here we have problems with the
regulations um but at the same point if
you refer to this this statute and we
there's some we want to move forward
with kind of delineating difference
between a brook trout and a rainbow
trout um how do we go about that can you
do that in regulation if there's a law
like this already on the books the way
tra yeah just have to follow what when
you do the regulation you have to follow
the law so if you're looking to change
depending on how much of that definition
you you want to change you would have to
change the regulation if it's in law
you'd have to change the law um we can
make a
rule try to was careful we can we can
create an administrative rule as long as
we don't conflict with an existing
statute I guess the best way I explain
so if the definition is in
law and and we're looking to change that
we would have to change law and then
refine the rest of it in the
recommendation and I I thought all of
this was in I thought the definition
already yeah that's what my question is
the definition is in statute and your
regulations refer to the definition so
it seems like we kind of have to change
it in statute if we want the regulation
reflect it or repeal the definition and
let you define your own
right represent
Spain thank you Mr chair and thank you
for entertaining me one more time
Colonel Jordan um it becomes my question
based on what the chair has asked you if
a definition in statute is overly Broad
can it be refined and narrowed within
rules without violating that it can as
long as you don't inflict the
stat follow up so would a an acceptable
method to address this situation be to
ensure that the the statute is defined
broadly enough to allow fishing game to
refine the definitions within their
rules generally speaking yes that that
would be best way to move my if you're
if you're asking uh and I'm not sure you
are uh asking for a recommendation my
recommendation would be to work on this
uh with Jason Chief fish and Paul who
was our administ Ru person and I think
we can avoid those conflicts because I
think you need to be careful that yes
thank you representative wolf I think
you had your hand up are you all
set thank you Mr chairman
but then are you saying that in this
case it can be reworked or do we need to
uh amend the statute out of
existence uh you could do both actually
depending on what your goal is so if you
wanted to if you wanted if you're
looking to change the definition we have
to review how it is in statute
first to make sure that we make that
change in statute what representa Spain
was talking about was keeping that
definition in statute as broad as we
possibly could and
refining the details if you will in R
and his question was can we do that and
I believe we can that the issue becomes
if if we have a law that tells us one
thing we try to create a rule to
conflict with that you cannot do
that thank you Mr chairman I think
working with those two groups
I don't want to say but a group working
together I
think a so it sounds like you would
support us retaining this bill for
another year to work on it I can't tell
you that I can tell you I support that I
don't
know thank you any other questions for
the
colonel representative
mckitrick thank you Mr
chairman uh as it is currently as as
current practice is for efficient game
uh is there a problem now that this is
correcting we that the agency I think
I'm safe to say the agency doesn't feel
its problem a constituent has brought it
to our attention we don't feel there a
problem we've been working with it for
years and our concern is if we're not I
think if I heard Jason correctly if
we're not careful how we do it then we
could have some really significant
unintended problems so that's that's why
I encourage us all to work together to
try and do that for thank you for your
question than
you thank you Colonel I'm going to trade
your hot seat with another fishing gave
employee and bring Colonel oh I'm sorry
one more M representative Smith go ahead
thank you Mr chairman thank you Colonel
I just have it's I'm backing up a little
bit and uh I would imagine you can
answer this the New Hampshire Timber
owner association gentleman that spoke
earlier said he had a big concern for
land owners regarding the this
definition change in I would imagine
it's from a law enforcement perspective
regarding these small creeks and Brooks
running through their
property I I would imagine what Jason
was referring to as he's his clients are
concern is land owners are concerned
that uh any restrictions that may be put
on these water bodies affecting the way
they use their props yes that was his
concern another another reason to do
slow thank you thank any other questions
for Colonel Jordan thank you than you
Colonel for speaking uh we'll go to Paul
Sanderson with the New Hampshire fishing
game uh thank you Mr chair members of
the committee I hope you can hear me um
I yes uh I just wanted to uh re
reiterate a couple of points here and
suggest a possible procedural resolution
for you uh the colonel was absolutely
correct when he indicated that we cannot
as a matter of administrative rul making
adopt a provision that is inconsistent
with an existing statute
so one of the methods that could be used
here to resolve the questions of the
constituent and which we have used
several times in the past recent past is
to receive a petition to the fishing
Game Commission and executive director
as our rulem makers giving us very
specific indications of what they feel
are the problems at that point we can go
forward and make a determination as to
whether there needs to be a change in
our administrative rules based upon the
problem that the constituent would like
to solve we may or may not need a
statutory change in this definition we
would suggest probably we don't but we
don't know that yet until we've gone
through that process of petition and
hear the specific concerns of
individuals as noted by Mr angers he has
seen us over the past several years
handle this with other types of issues
receiving petitions for rulemaking and
trying to resolve them and so uh when
the chairman just indicated that there
may be a potential to retain the bill
what that means is you retain control
over the issue and if we in fact receive
a petition we can show you how we are in
the work in the uh process of resolving
this with the constituent in an effort
that will cause um minimal harm to our
existing scheme of Regulation minimal
harm to Timberland owners and minimal
concern for others so I would
respectfully suggest to you that there
is a way under existing law in RSA 541a
for us to receive the petition try to to
resolve the concerns of the constituent
and report back to you on all of those
efforts so you can make the policy
determination as to we whether or not
we've made the right
decision thank you Mr Sanderson any
questions from Mr
Sanderson represent
Spen thank you Mr chair and thank you
Paul for taking my question
um to shorten up what you just said
you're suggesting that if we retain you
can work on it and we can judge
everything later correct exactly
representative this is very similar to
the concern that you had raised in a
previous session about uh the types of
firearms that could be used for taking
of turkey that we are resolving through
our rulemaking process meanwhile
reporting back to the committee on our
progress any further questions for Mr
Sanderson there be none thank you Mr
Sanderson next up is Dr Rick van
deul
thank you Mr chair uh Rick vandero I
live in sandwich I'm speaking today on
behalf of tin Mountain for which I'm the
research director in the last 12 years
tin Mountain has restored 24 different
streams uh for roughly 26 and a half
miles to improve it for trout habitat
and as such we have a vested interest in
how the definition of wildbrook trout is
separate from the generalized Je of
trout which includes as the law states
rainbow trout brown trout lock lemon
trout we have uh Eastern brook trout uh
Sal salvelinus falis which is uh our our
only native and I would encourage uh as
it appears that this bill will be
retained that uh we seek to Define wild
brook trout independent of the other
species so that those of us that are
working hard to
improve angular opportunities for wild
or native trout runs have the option of
doing so without having any conflicts of
introduced or stock species that are not
native so just in in short just if we
could encourage the committee to look at
a bill that separates the native or wild
species out from the others that would
be very helpful and I think for your
time thank you do any questions for Mr
Vandal see them thank you sir is there
anybody else who wish to testify in
house 241 relative to book
trap Colonel would you mind stepping up
to the mic again represent Spain has a
question for
you thank you Mr chair and thank you
Colonel again um just a question that
was brought up to my mind uh that I
wanted to ask about as well since we
likely May retain this want to ensure
that we're working with fish and game on
things would the change in definition
that specified the Eastern brook trout
as the native trout in any way affect
your
restocking program it could yes so
that's another reason to move slower as
as Jason I think Jason alluded to that
that could have a long-term effect on
how we St
fact it may change a particular lot of
body that we stocking now on our
Ang they taking fish to create a
situation where you wouldn't stop that
so that's a that's a concern those are
definitely different features of bra
Point another reason I think to move to
retain it and move as a with an
opportunity for all these people to have
I think that's
key thank you Colonel uh represent uh
there's a gentleman on in attendees
named Kevin Kevin if you get State your
full name and where you're from and
you'll be
[Music]
unmuted Kevin go ahead
sir thank you Mr chairman uh my name is
Kevin Gordon I in Bethlehem New
Hampshire I am speaking on behalf of
native fish
Coalition uh we are speaking in
opposition to this bill uh we agree that
there is definitely confusion with the
current definition of brook trout uh but
we would also agree that we would like
to see potentially that broaden to cover
all the species under the definition of
trout being brook trout rainbow trout
brown trout
and even lake trout you know should be
considered there too uh and that way you
know instead of defining those other
species as brook trout we're defining
trout as a general so that the current
rules can continue to be enforced but
then you know we're kind of clearing up
some of that confusion with how brook
trout are seen and it would allow the
brook trout to be then later defined in
more specific rules developed for
defining wild native brook
trout than can qu your first and last
name please it's Kevin
Gordon and you're from where SMI
Bethlehem New Hampshire thank you very
much any questions for
Kevin seeing none thank you Kevin next
up is Nate Hill
Nate just remember to unmute
yourself goad Mr Hill hi uh my name is
Nathan Hill and I am also of native fish
Coalition um I had Kevin join me today
because I wasn't sure I would be able to
get here I'm watching my two kids today
um but I would just reiterate what Kevin
said we feel that there's definitely um
a need to
redefine um in our laws the term brook
trout uh currently an issue with the
term brook trout is that although in in
the rules it is defined as representing
all fish from a uh law enforcement
perspective it's it's a challenge
because if somebody does keep other fish
or even Brook Trout from a said water um
because on the signage it says brook
trout um not all species it is not as
clear as it could be as to what the
current regulations are and we feel that
um by defining it as trout it would
clarify the definitions while also not
misdefined our our native heritage fish
which is brook trout and as Kevin said
it would allow us to at a later time use
the definition definition of brook trout
more accurately in in making new laws
and
rules thank you m Hill any questions
from Mr
Hill thank you Mr Hill and we'll go to
back to uh give the prime sponsor the
last conversation point so
representative avalene aani if you want
to
speak thank you Mr chairman just a
question on process um um I missed a
gentleman's last name whose name was
Paul from fishing game so my apologies
for that gentleman um would they be
reaching out to Mr Wallace for the
petition to change the rules or is that
something I need to
initiate so I'll answer it and the
colonel can shake his head no if I'm
wrong um the petition any citizen can
put a petition into the fishing Game
Commission to have them change a
regulation so I think the idea would be
someone would SM a petition to fishing
game we would retain the bill and
fishing game acted in need of the change
in law that would give us a vehicle next
year to be able to make that change
necessary if I did I say that all right
ah he's shaking his head yes I got it
right thank you Mr chairman and and just
a quick followup if I may you
may um would would fishing game be
reaching out to Mr Wallace or does Mr
Wallace need to reach out to fishing
team I just want to make sure I'm clear
with Mr
Wallace yeah so that they have to
petition fishing game and that can be as
simple as just writing a letter to
fishing
game fantastic thank you very much Mr
chairman members of the committee and
fishing
game and Mr Walsh you have your last say
I think you were the original originator
of this bill actually I've just as I
said back in my class I'm kind of half
keeping my ears open so um so I'm just
wondered my next step would be to
contact
the
commission yep just write a letter the
fishing game identify the statute and
the um fishing games uh regulation you
like changed and they will take it from
there okay I'm I'm really happy at the
process I'm glad the discussion is
happening um I from what I understand if
like I said if I'm hearing things you
guys are just going to sort of put this
on hold for a little bit while we look
at other
ways and if we need to come back and do
it I'm just my concern is just to make
sure that the guys in those 16 waters
you know the brook trout there get get
the protection um and if that does it
I'm I'm happy there um as I mentioned
there was a bunch of conversations you
know the ancillary things that sort of
you know opening this Pandora's Box May
remain that issue which I was hoping to
avoid but apparently that's not might
not be possible but uh I just want to
thank you guys all for your time and the
consideration I really enjoyed listening
to the discussion um and I will follow
up with uh the commission
thank you Mr Walsh thank you anything
else we go for the committee on house
bill
241 seeing none we'll close House Bill
241 public hearing I'm going to take a
two-minute bio break because I expect
the next Committee hearing to go for a
significant long time so needs to get up
and use the restroom can do so um and
we'll come back in about two to three
minutes
do
you
met
years
you
he is a
name oh yeah
yeah yeah
lost
[Music]
okay
right that's that would be a great way
to go
[Music]
it's
okay
all
right so if everyone can take their seat
we again and come back and start the
next
[Music]
pill
all right so we're going to call this
meeting back to order um we'll be moving
on to House Bill 118 Rel of the Fish and
Game Commission I recognize
representative Harvey for the purpos of
introducing her bill representative
Harvey all
yours sorry about that thank you Mr
chairman and uh I thank committee for
letting me uh present this amendment it
is really good finally to get to see um
some of my friends that I've worked with
for a couple years and hopefully over
the next uh year or so I'll get to meet
the new people so I missed you um so
first what I'd like to do is to explain
the process that I followed in order to
craft this bill because I really do
think that a process is just as
important if not even more important
than the bill itself um we've had
uh eight commission bills come before
our committee this is the ninth um it's
kind of like a merry ground and it's a a
little bit of a waste of time and
taxpayer dollars so last year as we were
debating um the eth commission bill I
made a promise from the well that I take
very very
seriously um that if the legislature
would allow me the time to work um I
would work with all the parties at the
table to Divi to to Define what issues
exist and hopefully find a way that we
could resolve them so that we can get
off this merry ground um this is what
legislators are tasked to do they're
tasked to find the problems and then to
fix them I heard many times this morning
uh Colonel Jordan uh saying that some of
our um statutes need to be updated and
perhaps um this is one of them now I
will say Co slowed me down quite a bit
but um over the summer and the early
fall I was able to contact the oton
society uh the Land Conservancy the
society for Forest protection um New
Hampshire fishing game The Wildlife
Federation the wildlife Co Coalition um
some individual Commissioners and uh
some individual past and present um
committee members I even contacted New
Hampshire Association of um conservation
committ comms which is a commission that
oversees all conservation Commissions in
the state although they conservation
commissions do not come under the
purview of New Hampshire fishing game
and together um all of these
organizations helped me to craft this
bill I sent it out to all the parties
that I just mentioned and we began
negotiations to amend it I spent six
hours in two days with New Hampshire
fishing game I spoke at the Wildlife
Federation December's meeting and I
answered many many emails from The Big
Three that's the aabon the nature
conservancy and um the society for the
protection of
forest sometimes I was able to input to
add their input into the bill sometimes
I disagreed and and so I didn't add it
but everyone had a chance to speak
clearly and um without any kind of
animosity so that was the process um I'm
not going to go through the the bill
word for word because you all can read
um but there are uh in my mind there are
three big changes in this bill I'm G to
start if it's okay with you gonna start
with what I would consider the least
controversial change and and then I'll
work my way towards the most
controversial um in my mind the least
controversial change is that I have
added e ecology as a possible area of
expertise to qualify if to become a
commission but I did limit that ecology
to fish and game
ecology I think the term is Broad enough
that way to include how things like how
animals survive how they depend on each
other how their habitats um um correlate
with each other how they interact with
humans Etc but the term is narrow enough
to to just talk about fishing game um as
important as it is I really don't care
about the ecology of the rainforest
canopy um courses and I looked the
reason I included it was because I
looked at courses that um are offered
when you begin a study of ecology and
the courses revolve a great deal around
Gathering field data and compiling that
data and that's exactly what fishing
game does when it sets its uh rules and
regulations for hunting and and trapping
and fishing which we've Ted talked about
so so much this
morning uh then if I skip back to the
beginning of the bill uh one one of the
biggest changes is the term sporting
clubs was changed to nominating clubs
because at this point in the bill that's
what they're doing they are submitting a
nomination um to the governor as a
possible U candidate for a commission
when there is an open seat um we in my
meeting with New Hampshire fishing game
we must spent an hour on that just that
term and I I believe um it was
commissioner Hodgkins that came up with
that term and and I agreed to it because
I I think that very clearly defines what
the organization is doing at that point
the biggest issue and probably the
elephant in the room and that is the
requirement to have a hunting fishing or
traffing license many there's many
legislators out there who want this
requirement to be omitted um they argue
that it's capricious that it's
unnecessary um I don't agree I I see the
value of the education and the
experience that comes with having a
license equally and fairly applied to
every County in our state however I do
believe that five years is way too long
in our mobile and our modern society
lives especially during this pandemic
have changed on a dime jobs have been
lost or jobs have been gained um
additional responsibilities have entered
the family in terms of um aging parents
or children
um the the whole family unit has become
redefined and so uh this amendment
allows the time limit to hold a license
to a much more realistic period of time
because it changes it from five out of
the previous 10 years to four out of the
prev previous seven it still allows four
years to gain the experience of hunting
fishing and
trapping I think our state could
actually benefit from Commissioners who
possibly hold their license their first
license for a somewhat shorter period of
time uh because those are the people who
might be I'm sorry uh rep can you make
sure you delineate if you're speaking
about the original underlying bill or
your Amendment because you're
complicating two together and I'm not
sure if people following the bill which
is on online and not your Amendment they
don't know what the differential is
between what you're speaking about thank
you for the correction I I am really
only speaking to the
amendment okay um was that what I was
tasked to
do the amendment's not technically
before the committee I'll allow you to
speak you on it but keep it kind of keep
it short so we haven't had a
deliberation we haven't adopted the
amendment so right now what's in front
of the committee is the or
um Bill okay and so I'm sorry um
obviously I was daydreaming when you
gave me those instructions so I I missed
it but anyway um so um I do think that
five years is a long time I want
Commissioners who who are possibly
having their license for the very first
time um who are excited to get out there
and and experience their sport um I
think sometimes sometimes um after
you've had a license for a long period
of time you can wake up in the morning
and say it's cold outside there's snow
on the ground um I think I'll just stay
in bed where someone with a brand new
license would say it it's cold outside
there's snow on the ground and I can't
wait to get my boots on and go out and
and Hunt um so this allows
um this allows some fresh new blood onto
the commission it and yet it still
allows a commitment
because up until now you did not have to
have a license while you were on the
commission you had to have it five years
before but not after you became a
commissioner so
by by um ensuring that you keep your
license while you were on the commission
I've actually lengthened the time of
commitment um and I think that's uh very
important because it does show a
commitment to New Hampshire fishing
game so I you've seen the bill you've
seen
um a long time uh you've had it in your
possession for a long time now I'm not
going to go through every single thing
in it but if you have any questions I'll
be glad to answer them at this
point Thank you any questions for
representative
Harvey I have one sure so you in
speaking about licenses and and the
number the number of years you must have
a license is isn't it an
indicator how do I want to word this I
guess I'm trying to struggle with the
idea of a person having a license for
one year understanding setting policy
for hunters who have been hunting for 20
years I I did not put one year in
anywhere you spoke about that brand new
fish hunterman who's going out and I was
I was speaking to your comments um not
necessarily the bill itself what you had
stated about new hunters and stuff so
the original bill um that I submitted
118 the original bill it's two out of
the previous uh seven years and if you
allow me um in the amendment it's four
out of the previous seven but there was
never a one okay thank you I I was
assuming that somebody with just two or
three years is still a newbie thank you
any other questions rep
Harvey representative close go ahead
than you Mr chairman
representative on this
bill how many people worked on this bill
oh my gosh um many um I don't know if I
could pick an individual author um me um
I did talk with nature conservancy the
udon the um Society for the forest
protection New Hampshire fishing game
Wildlife
coalition
um oh and um representative Egan who's
not with us today um representative
laflame was with me at time so
lots and who would fishing game help
excuse me M follow up go ahead sir thank
you uh who would fishing game helped you
with this bill um well Paul Sanderson
helped me with the bill but I also um
had I went over to two times this summer
and I spoke with uh commissioner sto and
commissioner
green may I follow up Sir follow up now
on these
amendments how do these amendments get
from fishing game to the State House do
are you aware of that yes how did they
get there I I didn't um you took them
over to the state house I I'm not
allowed to take them over but I emailed
them to house community services and I
asked house Community Services to please
um distribute them to committee members
I also ask them to distribute them to
the sponsors I didn't check on whether
they went to the sponsors or not um and
I asked if they could please make a few
um hard copies uh which they were going
to put on the table because I knew some
people sorry some people were going to
attend today in person and and not be
remote so so it was
Anthony oh gosh I can't
Delan I don't even want to attempt to
pronounce his last name because I'll
screw it up so badly yeah Anthony in OLS
also helped uh craft the bill and he was
the one that sent it to house community
services and then when I approved the
bill um house Community Services emailed
it out and I in this Co world I n quite
sure how to how this works so I um
called the chair and asked him you know
how do I do this and this is what he
told
me follow up
so what rumors are the flying around
fishing game okay that Paul Anderson
sent these over to the state house
that's incorrect then right that is very
incorrect okay thank you chairman thank
you representative close anything else
representative
Harvey anybody on line your hand
raised seeing nobody thank you
representative Harve
apologize thank you we're all set an
attendee had a question but not a rep um
next up is
um Chris shandler from the uh the
Hampshire wildlife coalition
Chris if you can go ahead and unmute
yourself that'd be
great yes thank you chairman Lang can
you hear me we can go ahead okay I I'm
here to support the bill um for a number
of years now um we at the New Hampshire
wildlife Coalition have been advocating
for a democratization with the the small
d uh of the commission we think that the
commission is not representative of the
people of New Hampshire we know how many
um people who enjoy hunting and enjoy
um uh wildlife in general and are very
supportive of New Hampshire fishing game
donate may not have licenses but donate
and and donate to the non-game fund Etc
but are discouraged by the lack of a
voice that they appear to have on the
commission um we think that the way that
the bill is written
now is um largely a pretty good bill I
think it is um representative of both
sides really and I support
representative Spain's effort on this
and thank you by the
way um I
would um you know I've been reading
about what folks who fear this um Bill
have been saying that the antis are
coming to destroy hunting rights by
wanting a seat on this commission um you
know and and of course that's the old
saw that the anti are coming I'm not an
anti the New Hampshire wildlife
Coalition is not an
anti most of the people that support
this bill are not anti we want to
promote good good sound ethical
hunting and unethical hunting as you
probably agree with me should not be
happening anyway so I think that having
a few voices on this commission should
not be something that's perceived as
threatening it should be something that
is perceived as a way to bring more
people into supporting the goals and the
the mission of the New Hampshire fishing
game that's all I have to say thank
thank you thank you Chris is there any
questions for um
Chris uh represent shirt with go ahead
youman oh I'm
sorry thank you Mr chairman just a point
of clarification with Miss chamblet um
we had the original Bill introduced by
representative Javi but we you speaking
in support of the original Bill the Javy
Amendment or the SP Amendment because I
know you mentioned representative Spain
in your testimony I just want to be
clear yeah thank you I should have been
more clear as well I represent
the I I don't represent either uh
support of either amendment I am I'm in
support of the general bill so um the
number of years that licenses are
required matters actually less to me and
I think many other people than does the
idea of having um some scientific voice
on the commission so that's what I was
speaking to thank you I appreciate that
clarification thank you Mr
chairman any other
questions seeing none thank you next up
is JB uh BJ wall uh representing himself
in support of the
bill hi my name is BJ wall and I live in
Sullivan New Hampshire and I've dis been
very dismayed about the makeup of the
fishing Game Commission and actually
even angry because I feel that it does
not represent the citizenry of the State
of New Hampshire and that's because only
a very small minority of the population
it's about
3.6% last time I looked holds a hunting
license and more hold fishing licenses
that's true but um the makeup of the
fishing Game Commission is 100% Fishers
and Trappers and that really doesn't
represent the population in New
Hampshire so I feel like none of us have
a voice on this commission and so I'm
definitely in support of the bill I'm
not exactly clear on which amendment um
says that three people have to or three
people may not have hunting fishing or
trapping licenses but whatever Amendment
does that I think I'm in favor of too I
I don't think even having just three
non-hunters on the commission is good
enough because you know 96% of the
population doesn't hunt fish or trap so
really I would like to see it sort of
open however that's not what the
Amendments read as of now so I would
support the one that at least allows
three
non-consumptive and well-educated
Outdoors people on the
commission I think that's all I need to
say thank you any questions for Miss
wall seeing none thank you Miss wall
next up
is
Tara Tara I'm just gonna say Tara from
the New Hampshire Wildlife
Federation T if you can go ahead and
unmute yourself once you're brought
online
uh can you hear me we can go ahead ma'am
excellent thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee my name is Tara gatau
and I'm the executive director of New
Hampshire Wildlife Federation the
mission of New Hampshire Wildlife
Federation is to be leading advocate for
the promotion of and protection of
hunting fishing and trapping as well as
the conservation of and access to fish
and wildlife
habitat with an Affiliated membership of
over 48,000 the New Hampshire Wildlife
Federation represents the interests of
members from across the state I am here
today on behalf of our membership to
oppose House Bill 118 in any
form for many years now we have appeared
in front of this committee opposing any
legislation seeking to change its makeup
of the Fish and Game Commission and our
membership believes this legislation
would do just that we do thank the
Bill's sponsor for the considerable
amount of time and effort put into
crafting the legislation and being open
and transparent about the process but
this legislation is not just something
our membership is going to be able to
support we have pulled our membership
about this bill and the possible
amendments coming forward we receive the
same response over and over where is the
crisis what is the problem this bill is
trying to solve and are there decisions
that are being made specifically by the
New Hampshire Fish and Game Commission
that would put New Hampshire wildlife at
risk the answer to these questions is a
resounding no New Hampshire fishing game
Wild life biologists are some of the
best in the business they continue to
report to the commission and to the
public on the continued success of
managed species and non-game species in
New Hampshire the very background
experiences and strong hunting and
fishing backgrounds of our current
commission makeup will continue to
benefit New Hampshire for generations to
come thank
you thank you any questions for
Tara seeing none thank you
Ty next up is Bob Switzer representing
himself uh thank you Mr chairman I'm Bob
Switzer from Sullivan New Hampshire um
I'm here today to ask you to support
hb18 and the amendment to the bill in my
opinion the commission of the
composition of the New Hampshire fishing
Game Commission needs to better
represent the citizens of New Hampshire
the wild animals in our state are a
natural resource and all our citizens
should have a say in how they are
treated only a tiny fraction of the
state population has a hunting or
fishing license and according to current
law this group of individuals are the
only citizens allowed to sit on the
fishing Game Commission the current
makeup commission is a glaring example
of minority rule this small group of
license holders have been given the
right by law to decide how many of our
wild animals are killed each year in New
Hampshire and as a note New Hampshire is
the only state in the US whose Fish and
Game Commission requires that all
members have a license I've attended
many Fish and Game Commission meetings
over the past several years and on
several occasions I've listened to staff
biologists testify to declining fur
bearing populations and recommend that
hunting and trapping limits be lowered
each time the commission voted to
continue with the existing limits I was
also at the meeting where the biologist
recommended a break in the year round
coyote hunting season for a couple of
months so that they could have a safe
period to raise their pups again the
commission chose not to follow the
biologist
recommendation I hope that being able to
have commission members with a view
towards conservation and educational
backgrounds in this field as the
amendment proposes would create an
environment that would give more weight
to the recommendations of the biologists
this can only benefit all of New
Hampshire's wildlife and its
citizens a wildlife agency's primary
mission is not only to serve Sportsmen
but to protect the wildlife that is a
resource that belongs to all of us the
New Hampshire fishing game's own website
states that their mission is to conserve
manage and protect these resources and
their
habitats there's already at least one
one state wildlife agency in the US that
is doing this and what this bill will do
and that is the Colorado Parks and
Wildlife Commission it's a citizen board
appointed by the governor the 11 voting
members of the commission include three
members who are Sportsman or women one
of whom must be an Outfitter three
agricultural producers three
recreationalists including one from a
nonprofit
non-consumptive wildlife
organization I believe that having mixed
group like this on the New Hampshire
fishing Game Commission would help to
balance these votes and provide a
greater degree of protection to the New
Hampshire wildlife that belongs to all
of us thank you for your
time good job thank you sir is there any
questions Senor thank you sir for your
testimony we'll move on to Mr Beckle of
the New Hampshire Autobon Society
thank you Mr chairman can you hear me
okay we can sir go
ahead thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee uh my name is Doug
Beckel I live in Conquer New Hampshire
I'm the president of the New Hampshire
ottomon
Society uh the New Hampshire aabon
Society is a Statewide conservation
organization whose mission is to protect
New Hampshire's environment for wildlife
and for people we support this bill HB
118 as amended by representative
Harvey um data that are documented in my
letter to the commission I'm sorry to
the
committee uh demonstrate that people who
are enjoy
Wildlife uh are about equivalent to
people who are hunting wildlife in New
England over the last 25 years at a
period ending in
2016 money spent on Wildlife watching
activities in New hampsh hire in 2011
which is the last year for which state
level data is available essentially
equaled that spent on hunting and
fishing
activities hb18 expands the pool of
organizations authorized to nominate
individuals to the governor for
appointment to the commission to The
Fish and Game Commission which we
believe more broadly allows the
commission to represent the kinds of
activities that enjoy Wildlife um both
um fishing hunting and for wildlife
viewing these changes provide
opportunities for the governor to
appoint sports persons with more diverse
Wildlife experiences to the commission
and more closely reflect the
increasingly diverse
constituency and responsibilities of the
new New Hampshire Fish and Game
department we urge you to vote hb18
ought to pass thank you for your time
and I'm willing to take
questions thank you sir is any question
for the nampan
society seeing none thank you again for
your testimony sir and we'll move on to
Joseph Mullen who's testifying on behalf
of the Congress Congressional Sportsman
Foundation Mr chairman can you hear me
we can sir go ahead perfect thankk you
good afternoon Mr chairman and honorable
members of the committee my name is Joe
Mullen and I'm in Grafton Massachusetts
I'm the New England State senior
coordinator for the Congressional
Sportsman's Foundation the 501c3
nonprofit organization I'm representing
today I'm speaking before you to express
my opposition to House Bill 118 as
originally drafted out of respect for
your time I will keep my testimony short
though I encourage you to read the
written testimony I have submitted the
New Hampshire fishing Game Commission
has continuously upheld its honorable
duties as the stewards of New
Hampshire's wildlife and Marine
Resources and I therefore don't see the
need to reform the qualifications needed
for the commission's membership uh the
commission is comprised of those who
have years of on the ground experience
in Hunting Fishing and trapping uh it's
my concern that lessening the number of
years in which the prospective
commission must hold such a license
opens up the real possibility uh that an
individual who opposes consumptive use
practices may be I to serve on the
commission uh just to wrap up I'd like
to reiterate my opposition to house
bill8 as originally drafted and I thank
you for your
time thank you Mr Mullins any questions
from Mr
Mullins not seeing any thank you very
much sir for your testimony next up is
representative Susan Aly representing
herself again unmute yourself
representative Al
me sorry uh thank you on representative
Susan Aly uh city of Lebanon Grafton
13 on I want good morning to Mr chairman
and the committee members I have served
on the Lebanon Conservation Commission
for 25 years now few months before I got
elected uh and um before that I worked
in tropical agriculture
overseas uh for 25 years I care deeply
about our Region's green spaces and how
they are used for farming hunting
Recreation mental stress reduction and
tourism uh the bill asks to expand the
scope of the Fish and Game Commission to
include aspects that the fishing game
department already deals with in order
to perform its primary Mission and often
emphasizes in its Outreach to the
greater public these include management
of our green spaces for all of the above
uses farming Recreation mental stress
reduction tourism and hunting and
fishing of course I put fishing inside
hunting
on they on they apply to the management
of game animal and fish stocks to the
Department endangered species program
even to search and rescue and to
enforcement against violation of game
laws including game
habitat on I hope that you will be
willing to expand the commission to
include some people on it uh I know
there are people good people in the
department working on these things but
uh quite frequently the commission uh
has not had enough expertise within it
to to listen to that side during their
deliberations and I think that it would
be a great help to the commission and
the department in the work that we have
tasked it with thank
you thank you representative Al nice to
see you again and there there any
questions representative
Aly seeing none thank you again
representative Aly next up is welen
Bosworth representing himself as a of
the
public yes hi I'm Wen Bosworth uh Mr
commissioner members of the committee I
assume you can hear me okay we can sir
go ahead okay I'm from Guilford New
Hampshire and uh I wanted to I I did
turn in a written testimony which I
encourage you to read but I'd like to
emphasize a few points I'll try to keep
it short all wildlife in New Hampshire
both Aquatic and terrestrial are held in
public trust for all of New Hampshire
not just for consump of users as was
implied by a testimony of an earlier
gentleman The Fish and Game Commission
has the fiduciary responsibility for
among other things maintaining a healthy
and sustainable populations of Fish
Wildlife and Marine
Resources however only approximately 10%
of the uh New Hampshire's residents
which are the license holders can serve
on the commission and have a significant
say in decisions affecting the wildlife
the other 90% of the New Hampshire res
presidents if we follow if we approve
the bill or the amendment to the bill
sponsored by Spain reeden Howard would
allow a greater diversity of people to
actually participate in the governance
of their public trust resources now
consider that uh the inequity of what we
have now with the commission of the 11
member commission three members are
members of the trapping New Hampshire
trapping Association so 11 members
27% of them are uh active and
enthusiastic Trappers and yet they only
represent
0.04% of New Hampshire's
population all this amendment ask for is
another minority position on the
commission um so who else is interested
well uh these are not the anti-hunters
the new New Hampshire Wildlife
Federation says in their uh somewhat
fear-mongering notice to oppose this
bill the New Hampshire Wildlife
Federation represents less less than 4%
of New Hampshire's population the people
that really want an input into this
governance are
conservationists and folks who recreate
as well as those that prioritize the
health and sustainability of New
Hampshire's
ecosystem over harvesting
wildlife and there are also those like
myself that believe that the commission
needs a more Val that some of the
decisions by the commission need a more
valid scientific sound Foundation now I
know that we have great scientists with
the fish and C department but as a
gentleman observed
earlier at times the commission has
overruled their scientific advice so the
bill the amendment to the bill would
Invision putting up to four
scientists on the uh on the commission
three from counties and possibly one
from the Sea Coast as I understand that
I see representative Spain shaking his
head but so um making room on the
commission for New Hampshire citizens
who value Wildlife for purposes other
than harvesting is an equitable way of
modifying the regulations to be
consistent with the real world it
doesn't mean the end of hunting it me
means that it might be more balanced
foundation for wildlife governance
decisions
thank
you thank you Mr Bosworth any questions
from Mr
Bosworth seeing none thank you sir for
your testimony I just let everybody know
we have looks like six more speakers on
this bill at the current time next up is
uh Dr vapo again um from the New
Hampshire wildlife Coalition Dr vapo if
you remember to unmute yourself once
you're joined in thank you very much Mr
chair and members of the
committee um I have submitted written
testimony and I encourage you to read
that of course this the four points that
I wanted to make simply is that we do
have a problem relative to the New
Hampshire Fish and Game
Commission for the reasons that you've
just heard it is not entirely
representative of the population of the
state now I understand that having
served on the study Commission under
Senate Bill 48 two years ago that the
sentiments expressed at that time was
that our commissioners are fine who they
are and what they
represent but I would encourage you to
look at the breadth of what the
department requires its employees to
cover management of
76,7 51 Acres protection of over 4,000
species of
wildlife enforcement of all the laws and
rules governing
ohvs hosting a wide range of educational
programs and training
workshops oversight of the marine and
Inland Fisheries and of course search
and rescue and I challenge the committee
to state that our commissioners can
adequately handle all of those
responsibilities in an equitable and
just way based on their
experience as a PhD science scientist
and wildlife biologist I too do not hold
a current hunting and fishing license
and yet am not represented in that
respect on the
commission I too have
observed having just looked at the fur
bear proposal for example for
2021 that there are no proposed changes
for fisher trapping and yet for the past
25 years the cpue has gone down from
over three
to just about
one that is a decline of a species that
the staff themselves have
recommended a
moratorium relative to trapping
Fisher the commission will probably
under its current composition uphold
that current proposal and yet the staff
not only in this instance but in others
such as was mentioned with the coyote
pop rearing time period uh has
consistently
been rejected at least their proposals
by the
commission I'm as interested in anybody
in maintaining the population of
Wildlife and maintaining the tradition
of hunting and fishing which I grew up
doing for 25
years that said I don't feel represented
and I believe through the help of
Representatives Blain Reed and Howard
with the amendment as currently proposed
we could help amarate that issue so
again I thank you for your time and I
hope that we can continue to engage in a
dialogue that will result in some
positive results thank
you thank you Dr vapo is there any
questions for Dr
vandero seeing none in the room seeing
No Hands raised thank you Dr vandero for
your testimony next up is um
um will Stewart from the stay work play
New Hampshire will remember to unmute
yourself and go ahead sir thank you Mr
chairman I'm uh as you said I'm will
Stewart the executive director of stay
work play New Hampshire we are a
Statewide nonprofit whose mission is to
attract and retain more young people
here in the granite state and I'm here
today to speak very briefly in support
of the intent of House Bill 118 so
attracting and retaining more young
people people is critical to the future
of New Hampshire right now we're the
second oldest state in the country with
one of the lowest unemployment rates
even during the time of Co and on top of
this we're the number one exporter of
high school graduates seeking a
four-year degree with about 62% of these
young people leaving the state every
year some of them come back eventually
but a lot of them don't so in short New
Hampshire needs all the people we can
get in general and all the young people
we can get in particular our businesses
need workers and customers our towns
need volunteer board members and our
nonprofits churches and Civic clubs you
all need volunteers to accomplish their
vital missions without which our
communities just can't function so about
three years ago stor play commissioned a
survey to collect data on why young
people stay in New Hampshire and why
they might leave the state and the
number one reason uh that we found that
young people stay here is to access our
state's unparalleled outdoor
recreational opportunities and we heard
that again uh a little more than a year
ago last winter uh as we went around the
state to nine Loc ations all around New
Hampshire as part of our policy and pint
series again people said you know having
and being close to these outdoor
recreational amenities was uh so great
about uh about New Hampshire and what
keeps them here so you know to maintain
and kind of enhance these unparalleled
outdoor recreational opportunities our
our Golden Goose if you will uh State
workk play does support the aim of House
Bill 18 which as we've heard seeks to
expand who can be nominated and serve on
the fishing Game Commission um we kind
of the way we see it is that allowing
more people to be nominated to and serve
on the fishing Game Commission will
increase the viewpoints and the
perspectives represented on that body
and that in turn will benefit how the
lands and resources that the commission
manages uh or overseas are managed and
will be done in a way that is more
reflective of how young people in
particular want to enjoy the state's
natural resources and outdoor amenities
so with that I appreciate your uh
attention today and uh thank you very
much
thank you Mr Stewart any questions for
Mr
Stewart seeing none in the room seeing
none online thank you Mr Stewart very
much next up we have Paul deau from
Grafton County Paul if you can remember
to unmute yourself that would be
great yes can you hear me
chairman thank you thank you for thank
you for having my testimony to the
representatives on the committee I'm
here representing the fishing Game
Commission uh so we originally agreed to
support the proposed legislation as
modified during our virtual meeting with
the bill
sponsor when the edited version was
available in print we took issue with a
few words and a few of the paragraphs so
we would like to take your attention to
page one paragraph three sections A and
B we thought we discussed this pretty
well and we feel like it was a misprint
or it just didn't get um carried over
well but we want to strike the word and
between
wildlife and the word habitat
conservation so in SE section three
paragraphs A and
B I'm sorry paragraph three sections A
and B both of those we would like to see
the word and
[Music]
removed if that word gets removed and
the rest stays as as amended during our
virtual meeting we would support this
bill thank you Mr deau and I assume
you're speaking to the amendment on
section three of the word and between
habitat and
Wildlife yes yes we're speaking about
the amendment made uh and uh presented
by representative
Harvey thank you any questions for uh Mr
deau of the fishing
game seeing none in the room seeing none
online thank you very much sir I
appreciate your
testimony next up is Susan G price Susan
if you remember to unmute yourself as
you come online thank you very much yes
can you hear me we can ma'am go ahead
thank you Mr chairman uh my name is
Susan price I live in Molton Boro uh our
land ABS 5,300 Acres of the Lakes Region
conservation
trust uh I'm a retired hydrogeologist by
profession and a very Avid uh large Game
Hunter Bird Hunter and fisherman
I oppose House Bill 118 because I
actually do think it's a trojan horse as
written I have not seen the
amendment but um basically by opening
this up to a
501c3 uh you can have people nominated
that belong to organizations like the
New Hampshire Animal Welfare
League um I understand the concern that
more
conservation organizations would like to
be
represented however um I believe this is
just a Toe Hold
to dismantle
Hunting Fishing and trapping hunting and
trapping specifically in the
State uh so I do oppose the spill I
think some of the comments have been
disingenuous um the sponsoring
representative uh I can assure you after
well I'm 57 and I've hunted for 48 of
those
years and I can assure you that I have
just as much
enthusiasm at 57 as I did as a
child um so I think there's uh some
disingenuous objectives with this bill
and uh I hope it will get voted itl and
I hope it will be on the table in the
house and never make it to the
Senate thank you for your time I'll take
any questions thank you Mr Price or any
questions for Miss
price seeing none in the room or none
online thank you Miss
price is there anybody else uh the
attendee list who wishes to speak on
House Bill
uh Gina you can be unmuted and can speak
yes hello thank you chair and members of
the committee um again for your time my
name is Gina scrofano I am a resident of
New Hampshire and I'm speaking in
support of hb18 as
introduced um as discussed today uh the
fishing game has many issues on their
plate to put it mildly um ranging from
those involving hunting and fishing
conservation to search and rescue um
we've heard from many giving testimony
um in terms of their belief that the
Fish and Game Commission is um is not
representative of the majority of the
public as according to our state law
they do have the authority um the duty
um to do so um so I won't speak too much
um on that I do agree with that
standpoint I just want to highlight a
few points of note that weren't included
that may help you
um I wanted to highlight that uh not
only does funding for the fishing game
come from General State funds via the
taxation of all New Hampshire residents
um but according to studies the majority
of funding from Wildlife restoration
programs and taxes from
non-hunters um and non-fishers so for
example in April
2017 Glenn normano the former executive
director of of the fishing game pointed
out during the fishing Game Commission
monthly meeting that more Pitman
Robinson monies which provides federal
aid um to the fishing game and which
come from federal taxes on guns
ammunition and archery equipment more of
that funding is coming from firearm and
ammunition sales um ammunition sales to
non-hunters and hunters and that
information was backed by multiple
reports including the Firearms consumer
segmentation report
which includes a segmentation analysis
conducted by the National Shooting
Sports foundation and Southwick
Associates um that is also true in terms
of the Dingle Johnson act which provides
federal aid via excise taxes on fishing
equipment motorboats and boat
fuel and that is logical when one
considers the fact that not all gun
owners are hunters and not all boat
owners are Anglers so this all
highlights the importance of equal and
fair representation from the fishing
game and it speaks to the importance of
having more broad perspective and the
expertise of those members um so that
it's adequately representing all
citizens and also to promote more
involvement with the fishing game and
potentially more donations to the
fishing game from the public who would
feel more inclined to do so if they felt
that they could become involved that
they were welcome and were also being
represented um amending the nomination
process by changing organiz ganizations
that participate from splitting clubs to
participating
organization generally which has
interests and specialized expertise in
Wildlife or
conservation um and also adds biology
and ecology to the accepted
qualifications of Commissioners which
this bill does as introduced is a
crucial step in addressing this issue
and I just would briefly like to add
that in general terms of creating sound
rules and regulations having a broad
range of perspectives and expertise as
vital um just as when crafting and
implementing legislation you know some
may consider a difference of opinion or
even opposition to a certain view um of
a proposal as being harmful but I come
from the standpoint that the more
perspectives you bring to the table the
more sound the final language and
outcome will become just as with the
wildlife cruelty Bill we discussed um
earlier today that issue was originally
introduced to the legislature in 2017
although the opposition did make it
challenging to implement um it put us on
a path to creating a more collaborative
and sound bill um that was introduced
today and I think that really is a
testament to having a broad range of
perspectives particularly when something
this this important um is concerned
really does lead to a more sound
approach um and final outcome so thank
you again for your time I appreciate it
thank you Gina thank you for your
testimony any questions reg Gina
seeing none in the room or none online
thank you again Gina next up is Sheila
Vargas Sheila if you remember to unmute
mute your mic
please thank you chairman Lang and
members of the committee uh thank you
for this opportunity to provide
testimony today uh for the record my
name is Sheila Vargas I'm the government
and community relations manager at The
Nature Conservancy here in New Hampshire
uh as representative Harvey stated in
her testimony she did Reach Out out to
us in regards to the bill language and I
here testifying in support of House Bill
118 as well as in support of the
introduced Amendment uh we just have a
few minor recommendations on the
amendment language and I did submit WR
testimony I know you guys have had a
long morning so I just want to provide a
brief overview of my written testimony
but I hope you will all take some time
to review that um so as many of you know
the nature conservancy in New Hampshire
does work closely with New Hampshire
fishing game on everything from our
landbased ecological and Wildlife
Management to our science-based
approaches uh to Habitat conservation
which are actually reflected in the
state's Wildlife action plan as well as
our marine fisheries and oyster
restoration activities that are very
popular and uh throughout all of this
work with fishing game we've always
appreciated the expertise and
professionalism of the staff and
Leadership of the department so we are
supporting the changes reflected in
house bille 18
uh for how a nomination to The Fish and
Game Commission can be brought forward
to the governor for consideration Uh
current statute reserves the right to
nominate individuals for consideration
by the governor exclusively to sporting
clubs in each County and while we
believe that sporting clubs should have
the ability to send nominations to the
governor for consideration we also
believe that they should not have
exclusive statutory authority to do so
the reason is New Hampshire's Wildlife
is held in the public trust and the
conservation of these public resources
requires cooperation as the previous
speaker noted decisionmaking from a
diverse group of stakeholders and
because of that we feel that the
interests of these stakeholders should
be able to be represented on the
commission that governs the department
so overall the changes reflected in hb18
We Believe do represent a positive step
uh in that direction and uh we
appreciate the importance of uh
licensing to the department both as a
revenue source and um as the tradition
and philosophy that hunting and fishing
has in New Hampshire that said not
everyone who values and believes in the
mission of the department is an active
Sports person holding a license as many
of you know there are countless reasons
why an individual who values the
conservation of the state's Wildlife
Resources may not have a hunting or
fishing license and our current statute
frankly makes it just more difficult for
these individuals to serve on the
commission even when their values
clearly align with the department and um
just lastly I'm not going to go through
all of my remarks here but I did want to
note that something as simple as
lowering the license holding
requirements from 5 to 10 years to four
to seven years as listed in the
amendment is a small step in enabling
additional qualified individuals to be
considered even um and as representative
Harvey said this is a much more
realistic timeline specifically for the
millennial generation who we want to get
more involved in hunting and fishing and
our natural resources they're known for
their transiency much more so than
previous generations and so this small
change to the license holding
requirement provides enabling conditions
for additional outdoor recreators to be
able to be eligible to be nominated and
right before I conclude here uh I think
the most important piece of my testimony
is I think um Mr dvo was his name he
mentioned the change from um or to or I
think it was from and to or um and this
is listed in section three um part A and
there's also um a listing of this within
section three part B so we support the
amendment if uh that and between fishing
and trapping is changed back to or and
with that I'm happy to answer any
questions the committee may have thank
you Miss Vargas any questions for Miss
Vargas seeing none in the room or none
online thank you very much next up is
Nissa
marks if you could unmute yourself that
would be great go ahead great good
afternoon Mr chair and members of the
committee thank you for hearing my
testimony in favor of
hb18 I'm Nissa Mars in hener um so
growing up hunting and trapping were the
only ways that my was able to have meat
on the table um and to this day our
freezer is still full of venison from
family uh and my partner and I have
allowed hunting on our land in hener um
so I certainly appreciate the many
things that hunters and fishermen do for
conservation and the relationship
between hunters in the land um I also
know that I'm the only one of my friends
under the or sorry I also know that only
one of my friends under the age of 40 in
New Hampshire hunts are fishes um and
yet my non- hunt hunting friends are
still Avid Outdoors people who enjoy
tracking non-game Wildlife or seeking
out rare birds um and my friends aren't
anomalies here um data show a stark
generational shift in how people are
using the outdoors um anecdotally we
hear from bait shops in the North
country that young people are coming in
looking to catch and release native
species rather than seeking stocked fish
uh or the largest species or the best
species for the fry pan um and in it in
the meantime um the number of hunters is
declining at a rate of about 1% a year
or more um in New England as a whole we
see only 2% of the population holds a
hunting license where 36% report
watching wildlife and 12% of people
report traveling within the region to do
so so it's not that people are staying
inside they're just using the outdoors
differently um we know that other
demographic patterns are changing too
and here I want to amplify what you
heard in state workpl testimony um
younger people are more likely to change
jobs and more likely to move more
frequently um and just as an example I
have lived in eight states in the last
15 years before finally settling in New
Hampshire uh and most of those moves
were to follow jobs um the way that this
bill reduces the time frame required for
holding a hunting or fishing license and
expands the eligibility requirements to
include the option of membership in a
conservation organization are both steps
in the right direction to ensure that
decisions made by Fish and Game
Commission align with changing
demographics in our state and changing
public interests um I'm a young
professional who lives here in large
part because of our native wildlife and
non-game Associated um outdoor
recreation and would very much like to
see a commission that really represents
the interests of my peers in the
outdoors um so for these reasons I
strongly support this bill or
representative Harvey's proposed
amendment and urge the committee to vote
it ought to pass thank you thank you
Miss marks any questions for Miss
Marx seeing none in the room or not
online thank you Miss marks I appreciate
it the last up is g to be uh Jason
stock Jason if you remember to unmute
yourself go ahead thank you um for the
record my name is Jason stock I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
Timberland Owners
Association and uh our our Members Own
and manage over a million acres in the
state of New Hampshire we interact very
closely with the fish and game
department we we run we conduct or do
landowner education we work
cooperatively managing
Wildlife U they of course enforce
hunting they enforce of course enforce
ohrv use across my members
property and we also have members who
have conservation
easements that the fish and game New
Hampshire Fish and Game department
holds we uh so anything affecting or
potentially affecting the composition of
the Fish and Game Commission is of great
interest to us you can see we we
interact with them a lot and changing or
changing the commission or the and
ultimately the the commission's goals
objectives and how they view Wildlife
Management we look at it from the
context of Science and law
enforcement um for us that is a that is
a concern um when we looked at House
Bill 118 we saw a lot of what we'll call
unintended
consequences um and you've heard that
throughout today's con through today's
conversation everything about the
501c3 to the licensed licensed
tenure and so that was those were
concerns that we share as
well the U and what's also of of concern
to us is I've I've heard of several uh
at least two amendments being proposed
again um haven't had the chance to look
at those vet those with our our our my
members and the folks that are actually
working with fishing game on the ground
um and getting their perspective and
that's something that again you know
before that the committee acts we would
really appreciate the opportunity to see
the amendment and have a chance to to
vet it because again for us this this
agency is is critical and it's it's
really important and I just want to come
back to one last point and that is we
view the committee or excuse me the
fishing game department and the
commission which governs it uh we view
them as a law enforcement and science
organization and we've heard a lot today
about Rec Recreation and including
Recreation and I appreciate that as an
individual who likes to recreate on the
you know in in the state I can
appreciate that but there is a
Department of Natural and cultural
resources that also has an advisory
Council that includes many of these
recreational interests in the state and
again I I look at what's and some of the
intent behind this bill and I I have to
question is there redundancy
with
dncr and kind of their mission to
promote Recreation to promote camping in
in our Parks as well as again Trail use
and and Recreation on private land so I
I wanted to raise these these points and
again we would be happy to if the if
there is if there are subsequent work
sessions or discussions about moving
some type of change to the commission
forward we'd be happy to to be a part of
those discussions given the importance
of this agency to our members but at
this point we we speak in opposition to
House Bill 118 and I'd be happy to
answer any questions thank
you thank you Mr stalker any questions
from Mr
stock seeing none in the room none
online thank you Jason for your
testimony that brings us to the end of
House Bill
um we will adjourn from that public
hearing and we're going to be going into
lunch I just want to give you guys a
couple heads up there are two amendments
to House Bill 118 as well as a couple
other amendments that are sitting over
there I i' suggest you take a look at
them before we come back to the work
session we'll be back in the work
session one full hour so at 1:50 we'll
come back for our work session at the
work session we'll discuss the
Amendments discuss what's going on and
then we'll move into executive session
um and vote on the bills are there any
questions from the committee on our next
process and um chairman L you had
mentioned in your email that the
Democrats could caucus in this room for
a half an hour so are you assuming
that's the first half hour or the second
half hour first half hour so members
come back they can come in the room and
not have to stand out in the hallway
okay so so we can stay right here and
and you can stay right there and I
promise I'll turn off the camera in the
microphone you know what I don't really
care it's all right thank
you so we journ till um recess until 150
thank you people miss Harvey you can and
represent you can hang out for one
minute I'm going to
[Music]
comeing I got my lunch upstairs oh sure
you right
be
another
[Music]
day excuse me we were here you know 7:30
this morning we were upstairs in 307
waiting for everybody to come in oh I
sent an email to everybody said 8:5 oh
people don't have email that I didn't
realize so I apologize for that I sent
an email everybody just saying here's
the outline of I knew something was
wrong I wouldn't look got be turn the
mic off and the video
[Music]
off
this is a
strange
you guys have discuss
what
discuss
[Music]
are you back again we are stting so what
I did
wasar
team complic rest isues and they work
with volunteer groups all over they
organiz their
own so what do you think about
these which which
one
[Music]
29 amendments
here
see
4929 429 529 I'm
sorry that was the
uh
animal you got a know on it yeah okay
well the the crew the animal is the same
bill we've had for the last couple years
it never gets off the
floor I think uh cruel the animals I
tabled it last
year and a Gentleman by name of John
from Finance table that the year
four because I'm a tuna fisherman I fish
I fish four days a week three days a
week four days a week when I get a tuner
on the boat I whack him it's like a
baseball bat it's called tuna FL pounder
and I pound the hell out of him so say I
cat a car fish and I don't want the
cfish I brought him up from the depths
he blows his lungs out I thrw him back
in is that cruelty to the animals you
know throw them back in yeah you got to
throw them back you can't keep them what
the hell else you done well that's it
you throw them on the seagull well
that's that's like my out there with my
mowing machine in Hayfield and you you
whack a f you got to put them down
yeah and Rabb same with rabbits yeah no
so
so what about the pistol the what the
pistol I I think we're gonna from if I
hear the rumors right we're going to
combine them uh there two of them yeah
they want to pass both of them
no we're not g to pass
them I can't I
can't I think what we're going to do is
we're going to combine them and put it
in a workshop so they can work on it
that's not what he wants to do he's
going to move to pass yeah what he wants
to do and what's going to be done is two
different things well he's got
okay do you know do you know him any
chance he's uh he got thr off the
committee last year for shoot the
squirrel so guys we're running a few
minutes behind
another minutes or
so he
yeah I think that's what we're gonna do
we're don't forget your mics are all
[Music]
live m is live
so you the button push the R
button yes Mr
chair press the red button it stays
on
e
for
all right guys if we can take our seats
we'll move
on
all right guys everybody in there see
we'll wait for representative
Harvey
when you're ready we're ready to start
the work
session all right I'll call the work
session into uh hearing we're here to do
a work session on all the bills that
were presented this morning just have a
general discussion uh make sure I'll
summarize what everybody said to make
sure everyone's clear on which way they
want to vote and then at the conclusion
of the work session on all six bills
we'll jump into the executive session on
all six bills is everybody clear on the
procedure great all right so first up
question Mr chair yes represent SP in
the work
session so the question was will we
allow the department or to answer
questions if a member has question he
answers yes that's why I asked the
colonel to come and attend in person so
first up was um House Bill 5 29 relative
the cruelty of wild animal fishing and
wild birds um is there the general
consensus I thought on on the committee
was an notop pass type of motion on this
bill that everyone seemed to think that
there was a good need for this bill I
believe the fishing Game Commission
testified in favor of this bill um so
we'll open up for discussion does
anybody have anything to say about House
Bill
529 there being this is going to be a
really quick work session what about on
video I'm sorry I wasn't looking at that
does anybody on video have anything to
say about House Bill 529
anything all right moving on from House
Bill
529 next up is House Bill 192 this is
relative to pistols uh permitted for
taking deer this bill was the bill that
adjusted number of calibers and
increased the rounds to six um the
general consensus was this was if I call
um a modernization uh bringing the uh
statute up to uh current technology um
and increasing the six uh the rounds to
six from five was an equity issue of
revolving revolvers and there were some
accidental issues where people who are
carrying revolvers if it was for their
personal safety you'd only have six
rounds but if you're hunting with it
you'd have five and it could potentially
cause a problem with enforcement and
after hearing from Colonel Jordan I
think we all he they the Department
agreed on six rounds across the board
was a good idea so we'll open up for
discussion on that summary and if
anybody has anything to say about
that representative wolf go ahead um I
believe that I heard the colonels thank
you for taking my question um I can go
along with this based on the colonel
thing I am opposed to raising the number
to Six and especially on the next bill
coming up so
uh it's a tough one for
me understood um again I think the idea
was to have uniformity for enforcement
Powers was the best best overall
answer any other discussion on House
Bill
192 seeing none uh going to House Bill
342 relative to taking a gain by certain
lever action Firearms um summarize again
this this would allow action car beans
in the pistol and shotgun areas uh
chambered in the same handgun rounds
that are already allowed in handguns uh
I think the summary was that while this
does increase potential muzzle velocity
as the that muzzle velocity increases
still less than some other rounds that
are already allowed through the new
technologies with shotguns and black
powder rifles and that um we'll have I
believe represent Spain will be bring an
amendment up into adjust the stat
statute that the colonel referenced that
um limits the number of rounds to five
and bring everything consistent with six
um was there any other discussion on
that I know there was some discussion
around
municipalities um and again my uh you
know there this was a properly noticed
um meeting so the municipalities is
along with the New Hampshire Municipal
assciation who I know from previous
contact very actively work looks at
legislation so they had a chance that
weigh in here and they still have a
chance to weigh in here as if we pass
this bill with an otpa it'll still go to
the Senate and they'll have plenty of
time to introduce and have conversation
over in the Senate so I'll open it up
for
discussion representative wolf I uh I
like representative Spain's Amendment it
now is going to make it easier for the
uh conservation officers to enforce the
the law equally everybody will have the
same number of rounds and their weapons
I am
concerned
that this bill May backfire on us and if
the people in some of these towns that
have voted certain limits end up Banning
things we're going to have some awful
egg on our face I don't know what else
we can do but I'm going to vote against
it for that very reason I don't want to
see further restrictions on
Hunting thank you representative so
we're speaking I think you're speaking
to the fact the towns may not understand
the message and the overall safety that
we were just talking about the fact that
these weapons are due to the accuracy
can increase safety but that message
going to get lost is that what you're
saying exactly thank you and we also
have discussion on House Bill 49 I'm
sorry House Bill
342 representative
love microphone please I have I have the
same concerns that the representative
wolf has um I don't want to see any
towns Clos down to hunting and uh you
know the the the thought that I had was
uh if we if we you know put this into a
subcommittee and invited towns to uh to
come and uh you know have Colonel Jordan
do a a uh ballistics and trajectory uh
demonstration for them uh you know maybe
maybe not maybe not you know just uh you
know not I'm not talking about shooting
across the room but uh you know but you
know bring some charts and um you know
get them to be more comfortable and uh
that way we don't we don't face that you
know it' be a you know a probably a
month uh you know difference if we
passed it uh this next session uh you
know um I I think we we ought to tread
lightly here and and cover our bases
thank representative of lepers I'm close
I believe you had a your hand
up yes same thing as I said earlier
about I was in miramac when that went to
marac and that was we had over 200
people show up and they wanted to close
all the land period and that was more or
less the deal we had to uh let pistol
hunting in Barac and Bedford was right
behind them and there was a bunch of
other towns
also I think here we we're just opening
a bucket of worms I really do I think if
we let this go through uh first place
hadn't had no public hearing I think
they should have had a public hearing
and you would have had quite turnout I'm
sure um I just think a little more work
should be done here because I think this
is really trouble thank you represent CL
sister just one of your concerns the
public hearing was this morning so again
it was a duly noticed public hearing
that allowed anybody who wanted to
attend to attend it was noticed in the
calendar um so I to be clear just I want
to clear up that Mis misstatement that
we did have a public hearing and
opportunity was there and and presented
for people to
testify not everybody was tuned in I'm
sure as always the case with the
legislature with 600 and 700 bills not
everybody's always tuned in to what's
going on uh further question
representative
con thank you Mr chairman uh I was
wondering can we we make the law but we
can we do like the town and cities has
to adopt this law by their own uh town
election so I I guess I looked at
Colonel Jordan understand I'm not sure
how the towns have how much power the
towns have to limit not limit um either
pistols handguns rifles shotguns and and
how that how that plays out so if you
want to answer that Colonel I appreciate
it yeah they can come up with it it's
kind of a complicated answer to it but I
hope I make you understand so that a
town can come up with any Town
ordinances that they would like they
cannot shut down a hunting season that's
legal in other places in the state that
they can they can restrict what's used
for a firearm for instance the problem
that that creates is as as a state
agency through New Hampshire bar the
20626 we can't enforce Town ordinances
so the only ones that would be able to
enforce that would be the local police
departments um so that that would be
complicated to do what you're suggesting
um if you are if you are concerned about
um how the towns are going to react I
think a better thought would be to send
it over to
Municipal uh committee and let the town
if you if you think that's necessary and
let the towns review it there uh if
there's a belief that they pay more
attention to that committee than they do
else I agree with the chairman I think
it's been noticed we've had it you know
it's been out I think if people were
concerned concerned about it that they
would be here but I also worry that a
knee-jerk reaction would shut a whole
town down they could shut their land
down and not allow people access to
their properties and that would hurt the
sportsmen and women so so I have a
concern about that I share that
concern thank you Colonel let to be
clear I just want to you said they can't
shut the hunting season down but they
could close Municipal land to hunting is
what your statement is they can come up
with their own town when they start
interfering with state law they don't
have that
thank you R
Spain thank you Mr chair I wanted to
clarify something Colonel Jordan because
it's uh runs counter to my belief as uh
someone who sat on the budget committee
and accepted donated lands to the town
for many many years um there was an
understanding and um a law that said
that you could not restrict that land
from use by every person in the
community if it was owned by the
community that they were able to uh say
for example take parts of the land and
say you can't use an ATV or a a
motorcycle on it but they could not shut
hunting down and we in fact successfully
made them reopen some lands they tried
to close in Deerfield when they tried to
shut those down after they were donated
to the town so a municipal parcel that's
owned by all the people in the community
cannot be shut down so that certain
community members cannot use it for
hunting in my belief well they they can
actually in some in some towns have
tried that
was a huge battle they were going to
close all their town I agree with you
they can't shut down the public access
to it but they could restrict certain
types of activity on it based on a whole
host of reasons and what they would use
I think in this case would be safety
they'd be concerned about public safety
and wellbeing so I think they I mean I
don't know I would think they would have
some success if they wanted to do that
followup and going on that we just
talked about municipal lands how much
governance would they have if I owned a
200 acre tra of land within that town to
tell me I can no longer hunt on my land
I don't think they could do that or
could open it to another person to hunt
on my land I don't think they could
control private properties I'd be
concerned just about town properties I
don't think private I know private
properties they wouldn't have any
Authority on but Town lands they would
so con to be clear the town could make
an ordinance relev only to the land
owned by the town but not any other land
that's owned any prly by any private
person thank
you any further discussion uh I'm sorry
uh representative dville you had your
hand raised go unmute yourself thank you
Mr chairman uh I I kind of echo the same
uh remarks by uh representative wolf I
think that
um uh it needs to go to Municipal
because even though it was duly uh
noticed as a a a public meeting I know
my town small town is dealing with a
myriad of issues and uh we have a new
Town
Administrator and I'm sure he may not be
attuned to looking at fishing game for
uh issues that might be impacting the
town I think it would be a matter of
public relations to afford the towns an
opportunity to to at least have a
hearing in Municipal so that they could
present themselves in that
manner
uh and uh if I
mean it sounds legitimate to me it's
good I my major concern was safety but
the the colonel and representativ Spain
have kind of allayed my my fears there
uh but I still think a matter of public
relation I hate to say this but public
relations Is to to at least give the
municipalities a heads up uh and to to
hope that it goes to uh the Senate where
they will deal with it we're often told
in the house we don't even consider
people on the other side of the wall uh
at least that's what my inference is
always been uh I think we we need to
give the M municipalities a shot at
because I I think it's it is naive to
think that the just because it was duly
know that they're going to show up I
think it's going to fall through the
cracks so that that's my uh my take on
it so we're in lucking that in this room
we have a former speaker of the house
that I can ask a question of somewhere
so repr maybe you can answer that is
there a way for a chair to well not
require but at least make a
recommendation to leadership that
um this bill be referred to a second
committee without it's just a probably a
preference rather than an actual
vote that
right so I I'd consider if we did notp
motion I would I would consider doing
that for the committee if that's will to
make a recommendation that this bill be
referred over to Municipal and County
government to give the chance for
another hearing over there that
Municipal Association could weigh in
on uh with that
recommendation uh your word that that's
what we we'll do I could support this
Bill thank you any further discussion on
House Bill
342 there're being on we'll move on to
House Bill 490 which I'm sorry yeah uh
permitted use of liveaction game cams I
think summarize the testimony I think we
heard there were a lot of problems uh
with this bill but there also some
concerns going forward um there was some
discussion around uh allowing people
with disabilities as well as uh creating
some sort of trespass statute there
talking about the fact that you have to
have the permission of the land owner
before putting the live game cam on
there so what I was hearing from that
was that we would ask we were asking
fishing game to go back do some Ru
making and maybe a good idea would be to
retain this bill for another year to use
as a vehicle with fishing game to be
able to put anything we need to into
statute um if that is not anybody else's
understanding we'll open it up and have
a
discussion representative close sorry
Craig uh could I ask a question of the
colal absolutely go
ahe so uh regarding this uh if we leave
this to Ru making uh I believe the rules
for tree stands are all ready that you
have to have permission to place on
private land and they have to be tagged
with your
name well I want to interrupt you lose
track many no it doesn't have they they
have to have landowner permission
representative Craig if in fact they do
damage so a client for instance like
what I use I
think you don't need land permission if
you cut threee GRS you do and you there
is not a requirement to have your name a
lot of hunters do that to
identify not a requirement for that so
go ahead okay it's okay I'm I
misunderstood then yeah I misunderstood
but I was thinking that it would be very
easy to roll game cams in a similar type
of scheme and we also have make we ask
to give permission so camera is not stry
it is something prior to the Farm Bureau
mention of it it is something that we
take a lot of question land owners are
surprised when they find out there is
not a requirement for it so it might be
in our best interest to do I spoke with
my rules Analyst at lunch Paul Sanderson
and discussed possibly doing this they
were in favor of in that
direction excellent followup uh not not
for the colel but just for the committee
at large I would say that uh uh I would
support going through the ru making
process uh
but restrictions on game cameras in
general uh would apply to everyone and
there's lots of people who aren't
hunting who put game cams out you know
we have our folks up in Pittsburgh who
feed the deer despite fishing game
warning them not to every year they they
still do but they have their cameras out
there or just as was brought up near
homes people use security cameras for
the same thing and they can be connected
to the internet and you can get instant
readings off of those so uh
yeah excellent any further discussion on
House Bill 490 it sounds like the when
we get to the executive session the idea
is we'll retain this bill use as a
vehicle after rule making to see if any
adjustments need to be made to
law there being done moving on House
Bill 41 an act relative to Trout um
again I think what we discovered through
this bill if I can all the testimony I
think this is the most number of
speakers we had even with the commission
bill um this Bill had the most number of
speakers and I but I do think the
consensus was this is um there's a
problem with how tightly tied the
regulations are to this definition and
the changes definition creates a huge
amount of problem in
regulations um and so even with the
amendment that we we put for that was
considered being put for forward um and
I think if I heard fishing game right
there what they'd like to do is work
with us on this bill to be able to
between Ru making and reopt you know
this language later on uh we'll retain
it again use it for a vehicle for any
Law changes that we need um down the
road based on the regulatory things
they're going to do we heard from Mr
Walsh I believe his name was who will
submit a petition to fishing game to
start the ru making process so is there
any other discussion on 241
Mr chair I'll just quickly Mr chair go
ahead I will just quickly say that um
the amendment I I drafted I I had
consulted with um local organizations
about the bill uh and had become aware
with the understanding that it might
likely pass had become aware of the the
language problems in the bill so I did
like two days of like a crash course and
trout and I came up with this amendment
which uh is an improve movement but I
wholeheartedly support um retaining it
excellent thank you we'll make sure we
get that Amendment over to fishing game
to help them with the beginning basis of
the
bill anything else on on uh House Bill
241 relative to
Trout seeing none next bill House Bill
118 relative Fishing Game Commission you
have before you two amendments that
should be they were on the table back
there and I hoped that lunchtime you had
a chance to look at it um each bill each
amend
does things just slightly different um
and what I'll do is I'll give a few
minutes to each um uh sponsor to be able
to speak to their Amendment so if people
have questions on the bill we'll start
with representative Harvey's Amendment
so if you want to speak to your
Amendment representative Harvey you
may um I I think I probably summarized
things pretty accurately this morning um
I told you how I with the process I used
to come up with the bill
um I talked about how um I met with fish
and game and um we changed participating
groups to nominating groups because that
was the um the duty that those
organizations were being task with at
the moment and I talked about um the the
license being reduced from the bill has
two years out of the previous five um
the amendment again
suggested by New Hampshire fishing game
was four out of the previous seven
um they they felt two years was not
enough experience and I felt that five
years was too long so there was a
compromise there and I think the last
thing was um the idea that um ecology
was added as a an area of expertise and
it was defined as Fish and Game ecology
so I I think I pretty much covered it
this morning um but I I'll be happy to
take any questions that you might
have thank is anybody have any questions
for representative
Harvey great there being none we'll move
on to uh re Spain Howard's and Reed's
Amendment um so they can talk about um
oh I got a question representative
close yeah
are we going to discuss this bill later
on or is this if uh we're going to go
from add this is the last time we'll
have discussion before the vote and what
I want to do is get the Amendments on
the table so we understand what we're
talking about that we can talk about the
whole bill as a whole if we want so
everyone understands how all the pieces
work together yes I talked about the
whole bill yep can we let let represent
Swain to his Amendment and then we'll go
on to the entire bill as a whole okay
thank
you
repres expain if you want to speak to
your amendment to this bill that you'll
be
considering thank you Mr chair this is
this is a bipartisan
multi-and amendment to try to rectify a
situation that we've been kicking around
as a
softball for for many
years
um we have made basically all of the
changes that the commission was looking
to have done in their
discussions uh on the other Amendment
but we have uh
specifically um added
a a
breakdown that says uh under the
qualifications for Commissioners
um we will allow one who's who's from
the SE Coast out of the
11 we have kept the fact that no more
than six Commissioners shall be members
of the same political party and the
reason we did that even though the
commission asked us not to uh is because
uh we feel it keeps a better balance on
the commission um
and technically if anybody decides to
call themselves Undeclared they don't
fit either party anyway so anybody who
is going to run for commission and is
smart enough to call themselves
Undeclared and I would say we probably
want really smart people running for our
commission is going to go ahead and make
themselves Undeclared and then this
becomes a
non-issue um but um we have said that
um we have allowed three members to be
scientists and
that person who's a
scientist um must have um where we get
to that scientist
list either a graduate degree or five a
bachelor years so at least three of the
10 Commissioners appointed pursuant to
sub paragraph 1A shall be qualified by
holding a graduate degree in one of the
following fields or an undergraduate
degree with at least five years
experience of employment as an a
scientist in one or a combination of the
following fields and we give eight very
specific fields that the person only
qualifies if they're in and they're all
related to wildlife management and um
and and uh ecology management here in
the state they are very very narrowly
uh defined simply because we don't want
to allow extraneous Sciences to be
considered for the fishing Game
Commission these are all people that
normally The Fishing Game Commission
already takes the advice of and we're
saying that no more than three positions
there the three positions will be those
uh and the rest of the 10 not counting
the one person on the Sea Coast Are all
uh regular as as we do now they're all
people who are are active Outdoors
persons but in it we close what I
perceive as a um a slight loophole in
the way that we do this in that uh
currently the requirement says you have
to hold the license for five of 10 years
but it doesn't say you have to use that
license for anything so you could
essentially buy your way onto the
commission by buying a lifetime license
and sitting on it for five years and
never being a person who goes out and
hunts fishes and traps and and be
getting that experience in the outdoors
that we consider so valuable to the
commission and that we want to encourage
so by closing this loophole uh we
basically say that you need to have the
license for seven of the last 10 years
and you also have to engage in The
Taking of game for the purposes of
hunting or trapping by having tagged or
sealed the game or The Furs or you have
to sign an affidavit under penalty of
perjury that you are an active user of
your hunting and fishing license and
that is my understanding having talked
with many of the Commissioners that they
already sign an affidavit when they are
applying for the position of
commissioner so this would just be one
more line in the governor's affidavit
that is signed for the executive Council
upon
nomination um I don't believe there's
any other big changes here uh we did add
the fact that they will lose their
office if they move out of their
district and they can be suspended for
um bad
behavior um and I believe that that is
the the nut and boltt part of our
amendment I have an additional comment
that came up during caucus and it's just
for the consideration of this committee
not necessarily action and that is on
page three uh Top Line This is the
requirements for those seven
Commissioners who have uh hunting
licenses uh be active Outdoors persons
should say and active Outdoors persons
who hold a resident fishing hunting or
trapping and uh in representative
Harvey's Amendment Resident was removed
I believe that's was a change that the
commission was okay with um I am fine if
this committee is fine with removing the
word resident and the reason would be so
that someone who has been an active
hunter in another state could move here
more recently than than say seven years
uh ago and still be able to
qualify so
those are the two amendments even given
represent Spain's use of analogy
somewhere between kicking a s a softball
not sure how that works but um malism on
purpose um so we'll go on to open the
discussion up for the original bill and
the Amendments and you know freefor all
anybody wants to speak on either either
of these topics go ahead um and we'll go
from there we'll start with
representative llam Who's online in
request to speak
thank you Mr chairman I actually have
two questions one question for you and
one question for representative
Spain
um I guess I'll start with a question
for you Mr chairman do you have the blue
sheet numbers for this
bill yep stand by one
second 36 uh in support 131
opposed
well at least
people representing Spain thank you um
you mentioned and I agree with you um
the importance of uh of having hunting
and fishing or trapping experience um to
the point where we we wish to have uh
the Commissioners well seven of them at
least um to have at least you know seven
years of of uh of hunting and fishing
licenses because it's very important uh
that they have the experience why don't
we require that for all the
Commissioners and we are exempting three
of
them that's a good question if it was up
to me I would probably go ahead and
require that for all of them but um just
as I feel that it might be hard to find
three scientists willing to run and that
who would get appointed and I had wanted
to put language in that said up to three
so that we could have three or less
scientists if we couldn't find a
scientist in that category willing to
serve um it might be difficult to find
scientists qualifying willing to serve
who also hold a hunting license and it's
one of the negotiations and trade-offs I
made to make this a bipartisan
bill so I have representative goalie in
the attendees I'm gonna let him be
unmuted and ask I'm not sure if he's got
a question and wants to make a point but
um normally wouldn't do that but he is a
representative so I'm going to give him
the courtesy of doing that he's allowed
to talk if he unmutes represent goalie
if you want to unmute yourself although
that could be
Heather thank you Mr
chairman I appreciate the uh time
um um bouncing back and forth between as
my meetings going committee and watching
your meeting at the same time
um I I think it it's I mean
I agree with a number of the uh
organizations out there especially the
hampsh Wildlife Federation uh opposed to
this bill I think the commission has
done a good
job there have been maybe a hiccup here
or there I think overall the job they
have done um some people thinking that
they have too much at to tasked to do I
think if you speak to anyone out there
in the community will tell you that for
what they had have and the staff that
they have it is remarkable the services
that they
provide um I will also go on to say
that
while some folks want to have uh
individuals rep representing outdoor
activities um I think a good comment was
made that the uh Parks Division and what
they do with the natural resources and
uh the board that they have might be a
better place for these folks if that's
what they want to do
um so I I think there are avenues for
them to be active in the activities that
they want um to partake
in um with that being said I I I as the
bill as written I would would not
support um I think the scientific aspect
um I we all know that fishing game does
have
biologists and highly qualified
biologists on board to answer any of the
questions that you may
get from having a scientist on board on
a commission um that's that's the
purpose of of having qualified
individuals in your department when
you're leading you look for the answers
from within and if you can't get them
within there are a number of agencies
out there that you can reach out to um
and we do that uh the director has
reached out to our organization the
Congressional sportman Foundation a
number of times for information what
other states are doing and we've helped
out with that uh at this time I I would
be opposed I'd be probably I mean
there's so many there are a number of
unanswered questions in which ways to go
um whether language needs to be changed
or re amended that it's probably
worthwhile to retain and work a little
further on it it's not ready for prime
time but thank you for taking the
comment thank you represent goalie
anybody so on the committee we'll open
this up for General ener discussion and
we'll start with representative Howard
over
there thank you Mr chair um I just want
to get a clarification here so I know
I'm looking at this the right way does
the commission make recommendations on
all the divisions of fishing game
department maybe the colonel wants
answer I think the answer is yes but
I'll let the colonel I mean I
guess the Comm involved with HS and you
know this type so yes anything that the
commission has legal or statutory
authority over uh has to be presented to
them so things like donations that come
to the agency uh proposed legislation we
cannot propose any legislation without
their prior review and approval uh
policy baking positions regarding game
uh Seasons opening and closing uh right
down to non-game and and Fisheries
although Fisheries is a bit limited
because of an old history uh law that
was a lot of Fisheries is informational
rather than
regulatory um so yes we B we as I like
to explain it to people that are
unfamiliar we as professionals so our
biologists which I will tell you are the
best in the country as far as I'm
concerned both Inland and wild we had
plenty of Staff educated staff in that
agency that does an outstanding job of
managing our Wild Life resources in
spite of what anyone in the state says I
give you any number of examples of how
that has been successful from turkeys to
boost increase deer populations they do
an
outstanding and then they make their
recommendations to the commission and a
very non-aggressive a very aggressive
non- game group uh that has really come
along ladies in the last few years in
bringing back almost extinct species so
we have the talent we have the scientist
as far as I'm concerned we have that
there so they make these presentations
to the to the committee and then the
commission rather and then the
commission has to view things a little
differently and this is where some of us
struggle but they're looking at the big
picture they're not looking at a Law
Enforcement issue they're looking at the
Law Enforcement issue and how it affects
the agency as a whole and they're also
they've got a consider social issues
something I don't always have to worry
about uh they have to look at all of
that so it's it's a it's a big
job but we have the scientist to a quick
followup so that would also include like
uh boater access yes y okay voting
access anything the department I can't
say everything the Department's involved
in but most of what the department is
well in uh this commission is brought to
speak remember it's like you it's a
volunt your uh organization I mean
there's no so you're you're asking
people with professional lives to commit
hundreds of hours of time to help us
with this that's what we're get so I'm a
little L of requiring education for and
this is just me because you given me the
mic so I'm a little lry sitting there
reading that of holding or asking the
commissioner to be held a higher
standard then would be required to be a
speaker of the
house or president
or president of our neither one of those
positions require any right no
bachelor's I shouldn't say that but they
don't require a bachelor so it doesn't
make a lot of sense to me when you say
three of the 10 should have bachelor's
degrees and then my next thought is so
who gets them what count is going to
have the Smart Ones how do you how do
youy that so there's a lot of issues
with
that you know that that I would but they
they
uh you know we make presentations to
them where they hold and they don't
always agree certainly you heard that
today they don't always agree with
everything that be present and sometimes
that falls to us sometimes quite frankly
they're wrong that's just the way it is
but it's a system that is designed for
give and take I think they make more
right
decision no thank you for the answer
I'm so represent Harvey go but I figured
you might want to dig yourself out of
that hole you just the
spe representative Harvey go
ahead so I I hear everything that you're
saying um Colonel Jordan and and I can
appreciate that um you know I kind of
agree with bachelors and and Masters and
PhD and so forth and that's why in my
Amendment um I just called it coursework
because there's many courses that are
offered by various um organizations
adult education uh the call program in
Keen um Harris Center episcop Park and
um they they're relatively free they're
local you can take advantage of them and
it's good education but the um although
I'm not opposed to uh a scientist I have
a master's plus 15 my husband's a PhD in
Immunology so I'm not opposed to a
scientist but it might be something that
we should consider um and the other
thing that's left out of um the bill is
volunteer work you know we have many
volunteers out there that work in um
support a fishing game I'm sure you see
that in your non-game department so um
you know there are still some questions
um but I and I just bring this up
because you mentioned it but as a whole
I I don't necessarily have a problem
with that but it it is something that
that as uh representative goolie and you
mentioned that maybe we want to think
about a little bit more and the other
thing to remember I think is it's
important is that the the biologist the
the Fisheries biologist Wild Life
biologist non game the law enforcement
people are doing it 40 hours or better
every week and we're asking
Commissioners to come in on a very
limited time frame to make these
decision so they really have to rely on
the information that we bring that's why
you know it has to be good information
quality information I think it's more
important to worry about that end of the
building being at a level of science
and and skilled at their
jobs more so than the volunteer group
that's going to spend 4 hours a month
basic a lot more certainly not 4 right
so so oh I'm sorry so I guess I'm I'm
asking I don't know where we are in our
deliberations here you you call this a
work session so and and representative
Reed brought up the idea of um taking
out the word resident so I don't know if
we're you know thinking about changing
that we want in either of the Amendments
or are
we I I'm asking we're in work session
right now everything is on the table to
discuss okay so so that that's my
discussion with that although I'm happy
with leaving that alone I would like the
resident taken out um and just my two
cents or four cents representative Reed
uh thank you so just a couple points of
clarification and and I brought up the
thing about resident in case this
committee wanted to have another
amendment drafted that removed that also
we may just decide to um support an
amendment either on the floor or in the
Senate to do uh that but um I just
wanted to put it out there the point
about um education so obviously just
because it's something most of my stuff
is in election law uh elected officials
when you're elected the people have a
right to be represented by who they
select and so if they select someone who
is completely uneducated it's still
their choice so that's why we can't have
requirements there's been numerous bills
in the past trying to put requirements
on people for running for office and
they are almost universally struck down
as unconstitutional because if the
people select that person that person is
their representative regardless of their
qualifications however we do want people
who know what they're doing in charge of
our departments in general and I will
point out in current RSA it says that
all of the Commissioners will have five
years experience in one or a combination
of certain Fields with which may be
demonstrated by the study at the
undergraduate graduate level or
employment so it already has a kind of
education requirement already in current
RSA thank you and you just explained how
I got elected
um representative love I believe you had
your hand up yes I did thank you Mr
chair um I'm uh I'm opposed to this bill
uh in its entirety um and uh pretty much
the reason for it uh last year we had uh
a bill I forget which one it was but uh
there was a man from Massachusetts that
came up and uh you know he was a a a
trapping instructor and a licensed guide
in seven states and you know had all
kinds of outdoor credentials I guess you
could call it and uh and he said you
know what in New Hampshire you have the
best bar none fishing game department in
the country don't mess it up leave it
alone okay um I think that's what we
should be doing you know we I uh
in New Hampshire for 55 years I have
never seen the deer herd in such a good
in good shape okay I've never seen so
many coyotes I've never seen so many
bobcats I've never seen so many turkeys
okay I've never been able to go like
Lake one basaki and and have a real good
shot of of of grabbing a five or six
pound fish you know uh those things
haven't happen and this has all happened
under this commission you know this this
group of Commissioners they they've done
as fine a job as you can you can ask for
and um you know I I if it ain't broke
don't fix it you know uh there there
were a few people that uh were talking
about the money end of it you know and
pit and Robbin some funds and and uh you
know stuff like that and now I'm not
sure what the numbers are okay I I know
I I know you know I'm I'm about $160 a
year in license fees for the State of
New Hampshire okay I hunt and fish a lot
and um you know I I I don't think too
many of these people that go out
Wildlife watching uh do that you know
this this fishing g game department does
not run on H sprinkles Bubblegum and
unicorns you know we we have to you know
the the people that are paying the money
should have the say you know that that
old saian he who pays the pipe chooses
the song um you know um it's got to
apply here because uh you know if things
don't run right and uh you know the deer
population starts go falling off or you
know you're not being you're not able to
catch some decent fish I'm going to main
I'm going somewhere else and I'm not
going to spend my money here you know
uh that that that have if on if it
happened on a widespread uh you know a
lot of people did that you know that
that' be pretty de devastating to the
you know the fishing game department and
now we got to look at that you know the
the people that are are complaining that
they want to see it on the on the panel
they're not the ones putting in the D
you know
thanks appreciate that for discussion
representative
Howard thank you Mr chair um just going
back to uh our Amendment um explain
reading
Howard I would feel more comfortable
under page three line nine where it says
at least three of the four Commissioners
I mean three of the 10 Commissioners
appointed pursuant to paragraph 1A shall
be qualified by
holding can we strike sh and put
May and that way there we're not looking
for someone to meet a certain
qualification to fill a position when we
don't have anybody stepping up to the
plate that be may not so under section c
you're talking about yes yes where where
it says shall we all know that shall has
a different meaning than May or
will and that would go to Colonel
Jordan's argument about you know four
ing at least three members being signed
well I guess the question is that that
would leave no qualifications for three
members when you put wh May in there but
I could see if you wanted to change
section c to say um up to three of the
10 Commissioners and then that leaves
some leeway if we only have if we don't
have a scientist apply we already have
one or we have none it doesn't matter we
could but would allow at least up to
three to be waved on the hunting
requirements and be able to be seated if
they're if they're a scientist yeah that
makes more sense I you know I just I
don't want to see us in a situation
where we can't fill a position because
we're not having someone who has that
particular degree to step
up
[Music]
SP thank you Mr chair since I had made
that suggestion initially I would be in
favor of saying up to three but that
would also require a change in the seven
out of 10 to say uh to remove the no
more than seven and and say at least
seven um because you would need to be
able to fill the other unoccupied spaces
if you couldn't find enough scientists
with people who met the qualifications
of the
licensing representative
Craig the language problem with changing
it to up to
three uh would be that I understand the
logic instead of requiring that three of
them uh be qualified by education and uh
experience but if you say up to three if
you've got your three scientists filled
and you're looking to fill another
commissioner slot or if a longstanding
commissioner happens to meet those
qualifications somebody's got to
go so if I guess the way I would read
that is that I've already met the
qualification under the hunter provision
I can be a hunter plus a scientist and
so you could do either or or both so you
would you would fit it either way so you
wouldn't have to just because you're a
scientist and a hunter doesn't mean and
we had three scientists you can't have a
fourth scientist that's also a hunter
and meets all the other
Provisions I don't know if anybody else
feels that that's the way I read it the
way Mr chair read yes um and I was just
explaining this to my neighbor here um
so the at least language is intentional
to allow that kind of overlap so you
have at least three three scientists if
you want more scientists they also
happen to be have to be Hunters but it
allows you to to have that overlap if
you say no more than or up to then you
run into the problem that representative
Craig uh pointed out but also you may
have a situation how do they qualify if
they if you say up to how would they
qualify if they're if if if you're
saying they they may they may be a
scientist so they don't have to be no
yeah I think I think we still leave the
shall in there the question is that is a
hard three or one two or three so the
the um the hunters the seven Hunters are
also at least and by doing at least
seven and at least three that means that
in either direction you could end up
with a commission of 11 Hunters who are
also scientists you see what I'm
saying representative love could we
amend that to uh something on the idea
of uh if no one uh steps forth steps
forward to uh to fill the seat you know
under these qualifications it reverts
back to the the
hunter you know that way we don't have
empty seats uh you know you give them
two or three months to to leave the
position
open represent
Spain so are you suggesting we we add a
um no suitable candidate provision
yes one second here I got to catch up
here
I'm trying to find what language there
it is at least seven of attorney
commission sh um representative Harvey
go ahead um so I'm confused if if it's
saying at least three then why would you
have to have a no suitable candidate
line
um I believe the the problem that's
being proposed is the case where for a
given County there may not be a cand
candate who
qualifies who is willing to do the job
or be nominated right right I understand
that but there's nothing in in here that
is talking about which county that
scientist is going to no that was that
was what Kevin uh Colonel Jordan was
saying you know how do we decide where
it goes so they can be from any County
but when a position comes up it's for
one County so as the governor has to
fill a county a position it is always
for that one
County so as much as I love to say this
because I hate kicking the can down the
road for anybody with the amount of
discussion we're having about amendments
proposals and
changes I'm wondering whether retain is
the appropriate motion to hold this so
we can fix the Amendments that we want
um and we can bring it up later the
other option is we pass it as it is and
we hope the Senate jumps on board and
does the changes we want which is never
a sure thing so um representative close
you looks like you have that look on
your face you really want to say
something yes sir I'd like to have the
major come up just for a minute I the
colonel I'm sorry I keep C to Major you
can call a major after what he just said
about the legislature I'm sure that's
fine
yeah I got just one question for you now
I I don't know how many years experience
you have I buy the hatch marks it looks
like 30
have you ever
ever had trouble with the commissioners
of fishing game just agreements yes yes
but that's what's supposed to happen
just correct like this one disagreements
where I when I've been able to come in
here and convince you to go in a
direction that we want and then
disagreed and go out accept we've had
that with the commission thank you
typically I personal experience I've had
excellent
thank you very much thank
you and everybody I'm sure has read all
about Commissioners in the book about
three pages I'm sure we're all up on
that I just want to say one thing that
no reflection on Mrs Harvey she's done a
lot of work on this bill but I don't see
this bill at all I've been protecting
the Fish and Game Commission since 1989
we first had the first bill when I was
in the house on the commission and by
God it's the same thing people were
arguing back and forth back and forth
and we got no place about it and that's
how it's been and I I've tended nine
years of it and it's been the same thing
change a commission change a commission
these men in the commission they give
their time up every week to come in and
do what business they have to do they
don't get paid for it and they get a lot
of criticism from all these so-called
experts in the state of New Hampshire
and I've been with a lot of them and
they're a bunch of beauties I don't
think that fishing game Commissioners
should take any slack from anybody
they've done a great job they keep us
out of trouble the department looks good
we haven't had no trouble with the law
enforcement department everybody's been
good and just look at our herds look at
our stock look at our turkey look at our
idea everything's really good in the
state of New Hampshire so when I hear
people talk and they want to do this and
they want to put a scientist in and then
they go to the page three and they want
a conation you know
controversion that belongs I need the F
Department not the fish and game
department and our department is Fish
and Game very very simple words and
that's what we should be sticking to
fish and game thank you very much Mr
chairman thank you representative
Reed thank you so there's something
called Survivor bias probably most of
you familiar with it as an example I
just read this story literally two days
ago uh after World War II or maybe
during World War II Allied planes would
come back with a bunch of bullet holes
in different parts and they measured
exactly what parts of the planes
actually had the most bullet holes and
they their immediate response was well
that's the the plane that we need to
actually put more uh armor on because
that's where their bullet holes are
getting and it was actually a
mathematician that came and said no
these are the planes that are returning
these are the planes that came back
these are not the planes that crashed so
this means that these are are the parts
of the plane that it's okay that they
they're taking damage on so that's
Survivor buas the fact that Hunters Avid
Hunters who you know I can say nothing
bad of they they want to have
conservation in the state they want to
have good uh hunting opportunities in
the state the fact that they are
benefiting from the current current
makeup is great but the people who are
not benefiting from the current makeup
are the ones that are being left out and
I have to to say we have no further to
look than the fact that you have heard
that there's a problem with the
commission for every single one of those
years since 1980 whatever it was right
the fact that this bill has come up in
some form or another eight different
times there are people who are feeling
left out and to say that oh it works
great for us because our people are the
ones in charge and they're the only ones
in charge doesn't mean that there's not
a problem and I will also say that there
are a lot of other states that have
really great hunting opportunities who
do things differently that do diversify
their commission put scientists on their
commission States like Texas and
Colorado and Montana they have excellent
hunting opportunities as well but they
do put other people on that commission
so I just want to encourage us to not
fall into the Trap of Survivor
bias representative Harvey mostly I want
to say to representative close that I
take no offense to anything you say we
we've been friends for a couple years
and I hope we'll go on being friends so
you go ahead and say whatever you want
to say I'm okay with it but I would like
to point out um yes I have read these
three pages so many times I think I have
them memorized and I can say it in my
sleep so I would like to point out
though
um when you say it's our their
responsibility is fish and game if you
look under the duties of uh commissioner
and that and number one number one top
of page 25 in my green book I don't know
what color you have but the first word
that comes as a duty of the commi
Commissioners is
conservation not fish and game it's
conservation and the second word is
protection um so so it it you know
although we're still friends I I do
disagree that it is just fishing game
it's it the the words right there are
conservation
protection close you want to respond yes
uh that was brought out at the last
hearing from the the new director we
have and the word conservation showed up
several times the director of The Farm
Bureau suggested that if fishing game
wanted to talk about conservation they
should come to the F Bureau that's where
that falls under not fishing game that
was right from the director or the
commissioner that was right from the
commissioner that's where I get that
from thank
you does anybody else have anything to
say okay so the one thing I I'll say
because I get the microphone is that um
I sat on a three-hour meeting with
representative Harvey with the
Commissioners discussing this very Bill
and it seemed to me that again the
Commissioners were open and and
accepting the fact that the statute
needs updating and it's why they're
willing to work with trying to get an
amendment out to get an amendment that
fit what their requirements were what
they felt their needs were um and given
the conversation again of the back and
forth around the amendment um and and I
think there's there's a majority support
for the bill but I think there's still
some questions around the amendment from
the discussion we've been listening to
so um I I I would think that again the
smart move would be to retain this bill
to work on the amendment to fit the
couple needs we had around you know up
to versus
um uh minimum requirement at least three
uh there was an Andor conversation uh
that came out as part of the discussion
in uh of the bill itself during the time
um so I think probably your retain
Motion makes sense going forward for
this committee to give us a a mechanism
to allow us to get the commission to
weigh in and work with us to develop
amendment that they feel works for them
um I to also looked at the fishing game
website and the first word in their
mission statement is conserve then
manage manage then protect sorry Colonel
um but uh but the first two has to do
with managing and and conserving our
resources and when you talk about the
fish end game there's three more words
that go with that committee and that is
endm Marine Resources and it's about the
resources not fishing game it's about
managing the fish the game and Marine
Resources and I think that it's not
unreasonable to say we want some decent
people setting policy for us that have
experience in the background so I think
that's also what the commission is
getting to as well so that being said
unless there's anything further we want
to discuss we can start moving into
executive
session so I'll open it up for
discussion on all
bills they're being done I will
represent wolf go ahead just a question
a point of order I if you take these
bills in the order that we've discussed
them 529 and
192 and uh
342 and 342 was the one that was going
to get referred to a second
committee that was the one I was going
to ask I'll make a recommendation to the
leadership that 342 be referred to the
municipal and County government would
you then leave it up to the second
committee to pass it or would we would
we pass it so we have to pass it move it
as a policy we agree on a fish and game
policy this works um and then they would
decide whether on a municipal policy it
would work for them thank you but my
question then comes if they decide that
they don't want it as a policy that they
shoot it
down then you've
got
um the six Six Bullets here and the
other one am I right I completely
understand I completely
agree Catch 22 with when we refer to a
second committee I have no idea what the
second committee is going to do with it
okay thank
you any further
discussion there being none we will
close the work session and move into our
executive session of the house uh
fishing game and Marine Resources
committee and um I will look uh opening
up the executive session on House Bill
529 and I would look to representative
Smith for a
motion uh Mr Speaker I'd like to make a
motion to OTP House Bill 529
FN thank you for that promotion but I
lost that vote um but uh I recognize
your motion for OTP and um I apologize
and a representative love I believe
you're looking to Chairman I second so
it's been moved by representative Smith
and seconded by representative love to
move OTP for House Bill
529 any further discussion
having no further discussion I will look
to the clerk to call the role if you on
remote and you're voting you need to
have your camera on for your vote to be
counted the motion on HB 529 is ought to
pass uh please vote by signifying yay or
nay representative con yes
representative close
yes representative Spain yes
representative Howard Y representative
Craig yes representative love yes
representative wolf yes representative
kitridge
one representative Dy is not here oh
sorry I
apologize representative Smith yes
representative Harvey yes representative
lfam yes representative dville yes
representative King yes the clerk votes
yes representative Martin sorry Jack
filling and repres thank you
representative rre is still
absent representative
shle representative Ellis yes
representative
oxol
yes chairman Lang votes yes and and
sorry Mr
[Laughter]
chair my apologies Mr chair this is my
first day on the
job
only if I'm lucky the vote is 19 to one
19 to one move
consent first off I need her to recount
because I'm pretty sure we don't have 20
I'm not sure do we have 21 members one
second we only have one person
missing I I had 19 to1 uh so approve
it's been motion at 19 to one to OTP and
without objection it would go on consent
yes moving
on House Bill 192 uh relative to Pistol
permitted for taking Deer uh I Look to
representative love for a
motion I make a motion of OTP this OTP
by representative love looking at
representative Smith for a
second I'm gonna say this correctly Mr
chairman I second that
motion so it's been moved in second and
for to pass on House Bill 192 has
written any further discussion on house
192 the motion the motion is OTP ought
to
pass seeing none I'll have the clerk
call the r the clerk needs a little bit
of time Mr
here all right the motion on
HB 129 is ought to
pass sorry
192 representative KH
yes representative close
no representative Spain yes
representative
Howard representative Craig
yes representative love yes
representative
wolf unfortunately
no representative
kitridge representative dsy
yes representative Smith
yes representative Harvey
yes representative
lfl
dville
yes
sorry no
worries representative
King yes the clerk votes
yes representative Jack
yes uh representative Shir yeah
representative Ellis
[Music]
no representative oxel yes and Mr
chair yes see It's tricky because you
come first but they have to skip
you the uh total is 172
three unless there's an objection on
commit to that bill go on consent
hearing no objection the bill will be on
consent next up is House Bill
342 an act relative taking gain by
certain lever action Firearms I Look to
representative Howard for a
motion it's been moved by representative
Howard for ought to pass second and
by point of order yes sir
we have the amendment on it so the
proper order procedures to move OTP on
the bill it's open for further Amendment
then move the amendment and then a final
motion of otpa thank you uh Second and
it's been seconded by representative
wolf and Bill is open to further
Amendment
discussion trying to find the right
amendment
number
Mr
chair ra expain go ahead I move
Amendment 2021
d136
H and representative
[Music]
Craig it's been seconded by
representative Craig to move Amendment
136h and it is open for further
discussion
repr explain if you could speak to what
your Amendment does absolutely this is
the amendment that was requested by um
Colonel Jordan and uh fishing game it
takes and amends to the end of the bill
language um an amendment to RSA 207
colon 3 to change five to six
cartridges and then under pistols
permitted which is RSA 208 colon
3-D again changes uh five rounds to six
rounds of
ammunition this makes it consistent
across all gun platforms approved for
hunting Under fishing game rules and
there won't be any
confusion and fishing game should have a
much easier
time thank you any further discussion on
House
Bill
there being done just remember that also
I this is the bill that I will be I will
make a recommendation to leadership to
refer to County and municipal government
uh committee after
passage
representative are you going to make it
as a recommendation or does it need to
be an amendment to the bill that it goes
to the oh we can't amend where in in the
bill where where it goes I can want to
make a recommendation that we move it to
M County government given its topic tit
I'll take your
word
any further discussion on
342 there being none I'll have the clerk
call the
rooll the question is on the amendment
correct we're call I'm correct we're
adopting the
amendment the motion is to adopt
Amendment
136h on House Bill
342 representative
con representative close yes
representative Spain yes representative
Howard representative Craig
yes representative love yes
representative wolf yes representative
kitridge hi representative Dy yes
representative Smith
yes representative
Harvey representative
llam yes representative
Dell
yes representative
King yes the clerk votes yes
representative Jack
yes representative
sh
representative Ellis
yes representative
oxel yes and Mr clerk I mean Mr chair
speaker clerk whatever I answer tooted
you chairman votes yes and the vote is
20 to nothing yay our first unanimous
bill without objection I go on
consent that's the amend I apologize the
amendment uh now uh we're back to the
original bill as amended on House Bill
342 as amended is there any further
discussion there being none the clerk
will call the
roll it is much easier to do this on
paper
Absolutely I'll have it included in note
to the cler to
cler so is there a new motion otpa
that's been moved and seconded the
original motion was OTP and the
amendment was adopted so now the motion
is otpa uh automatically without a
different correct okay all right in that
case the motion is
otpa on House Bill
342 representative
con representative clo
yes representative Spain yes
representative Howard representative
Craig yes representative love yes
representative wolf yes representative
kitridge yes representative dwy yes
representative Smith yes representative
Harvey representative llam
yes representative D yes representative
K
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Jack yes
representative sherff representative
Ellis
yes representative oxol yes and Mr chair
chair votes yes the vote is 20 to zero
without objection to go on the consent
calendar next up is House Bill 490
permitted use of liveaction game cams I
Look to represent Spain for a motion Mr
chair I would move retain on that bill
represent Spain is moved uh retain
seconded
by Mr chairman I will second that
represented by representative
Smith bill is not for further discussion
or
Amendment there being none clerk will
call the rooll I have not even been able
to catch up from the last one hold on
boy actually I have a
question sure go ahead since we pulled
an amendment already that C it in the
same calendar day should we apply the
amendment while before we retain and
then retain the amended version to work
on or should we just retain that bill
and then have to reapply another
amendment later there's no such thing as
amending and retain the bill you retain
it and then move it forward and then you
can amend it when you actually go to
adjudicate yeah my question was whether
we should do an OTP put the amendment on
and then decide to retain the
otpa no I that's improper procedure
because you would be you have to vote
down the OTP motion because that's the
motion that's
prevalent
yeah I think the proper motion is to
retain we can correct so representative
Spain motion retain on House Bill 490
and who was the second Smith Smith
represent Smith thank you very
much all
right motion to retain on 490
ah representative
KH representative close yes
representative Spain yes representative
Howard representative Craig yes
representative love yes representative
wolf yes representative
kitridge nay yay yay sorry
representative dwy yes representative
Smith yes representative Harvey
representative flam yes representative
dville yes representative King yes the
clerk votes yes representative Jack yes
representative sorry rre is absent
representative sherle representative
Ellis yes representative oxil yes and Mr
chair yes the vote is 20 to
zero calendar because it's a retain Bill
moving on on to House Bill 241 relative
to Trout um looking to representative
Smith for a
motion Mr chairman I'd like to make a
motion to retain House Bill 241 it's
been moved by representative Smith to
retain House Bill 241 representative
second been seconded by representative
Love Is there any further discussion on
House Bill
241 there being none the clerk when you
are ready
you can that was a trick I learned from
a former speaker well if you only just
talked like that all the time we
wouldn't have
[Laughter]
problems all right house bill
241 I'm sorry can you please repeat the
motion to retain it was motion by
representative Smith seconded by
representative
love thank
you
if I have to do this again I'm gonna ask
for
paper all
right representative con yes
representative close yes representative
Spain yes representative Howard
representative Craig yes representative
love representative wolf yes
representative
kitridge representative dasty yes
representative Smith yes representative
Hardy representative llam yes
representative
dville yes representative King yes the
clerk votes yes representative Jack yes
representative shle representative Ellis
yes representative oxal yes and Mr chair
yes the vote is 20 to
zero vote being 20 to zero retain that
bill moving on to house
bill8 representative Harvey for a
motion represent of Harvey has moved to
retain the bill representative
Smith Mr chairman I will second that
it's been moved to retain the bill by
representative Harvey second by
representative Smith is open for further
discussion
yes represent Howard thank you Mr chair
is that
working thank you Mr chair um I just
want to make a comment on the end of
this discussion in the workshop was
about
conservation uh I take the conservation
as in conservation of wildlife
Marine not conservation of wetlands or
conservation of farmlands so
uh you know I know it's kind of vague
when it says conservation but I look at
it that
way I would tend to agree with you
Marine I mean Fish game Marine
Resources any further discussion there
being none the clerk will call a
roll motion is to retain House Bill
118 representative con yes
representative qu
yes representative
Spain yes representative Howard
representative Craig yes representative
love yes representative wolf yes
representative kitridge yes
representative dsy yes representative
Smith yes representative Harvey yes
representative llam yes representative
dville yes representative King yes cler
one second represent King you need turn
your video on
please I'm sorry thank
you so cast your vote again
please representative King
yes rep the clerk votes yes
representative
Jack oops yes representative shotte
representative Ellis yes representative
oxal yes and Mr chair yes
the vote is 20 to
zero thank you you've already started
your work for next year on those three
bills that we've retained is there
anything else that come before the uh
house fish and gain and Marine Resources
committee I would kindly remind everyone
who made a uh a motion at least ought to
pass that they are in charge of their
majority reports don't need any majority
reports everything is on
consent nothing
calendar um one thing I remind everybody
as you get up and leave the
room and uh represent slam go ahead
thank you um and it's just a it's just a
procedural thing
um I don't think retained bills have to
go on the calendar at
all that's correct retain bills by us
yeah so as far as being on consent that
don't have
to um
however memory serves me even even items
on the consent calendar do have a
committee
report yes they sure I'll make sure
whoever made the motion gets uh it in
just in case we need it and it was great
to see you
all excellent anything else all right I
will adjourn this meeting and thank
everybody for coming and showing up and
for participating remotely and I I look
forward to you when the Senate sends
over bills and we get to do this all
over
again thank you thank
you